Four,
three,
two,
one.
Hey,
what's going on?
how do I get that quick,
quick fix.
Oh my God.
It's so amazing how fast it came back to
me.
Like the addiction of playing that game
over and over again.
That it's a real problem.
Yeah,
we've been going crazy.
Jamie has been fucking me up to.
So today I got lucky that he had to help
you get his shit together.
He really killed that.
He's been fucking me up.
Yeah,
you don't really play quake,
right?
You just from playing a fortnight and
stuff.
I tested myself a little bit because I
knew that this was gonna happen
eventually,
so I had to get some practice with some
rockets that at some point and yeah,
but it helped.
It honestly helps to warm up with quake
to play for at night or play pub g or
something like that because the quick
whatever it is of aiming,
you don't do it that much.
So like when you're doing it three
times,
you've already done it 55 times playing
quake just in one round.
So like your little interaction you have
with someone a shotgun.
Usually when so quick.
It's so fast paced.
Yeah.
We're playing quake for.
It's like
Jesus Christ.
I haven't played that game and maybe 15
years.
See Two.
You're ever going to do it again?
I probably shouldn't,
but what I noticed is my eyesight's
sucks now.
My eyesight is not nearly as good.
It's interesting.
From 42 to 46,
there was a big dropoff in at 46.
The fucking floor fell out.
Now it's like my eyesight's Shit Gamer
glasses.
It takes me a minute when I play games
to one game isn't enough yet.
It probably takes 10 minutes,
maybe less,
but like to just start tracking things,
getting your eyes up to speed.
The distance you are away from that
screen.
I'll all.
It takes a little bit of time to get in
there.
Yeah,
man,
it's,
we're right now we're just playing it on
the local area network.
But uh,
once you start going online and playing
other people,
that's when it gets super,
super addictive.
People that still play that game must be
insane.
Oh my God.
I don't want to be anywhere near
psychopaths if they're playing that
game.
It's because they're really good at it.
Probably,
you know,
like who else?
Like young kids aren't buying that game.
Back in the day you even had a Joe Rogan
a level that somebody created.
Remember that somebody created a level.
That's right.
Was that what game with three or four?
I think it was for.
Was it really for.
Was 11 though,
didn't it come out in 2011?
Maybe it was three days.
Might have been three wasn't it?
Wasn't rock arena arena for.
I don't know.
Oh my gosh,
I don't remember.
I know there was rocket arena for quake
two and there was rocket arena for quake
three because I started with rocket
arena for quick two,
which have you played today?
You would think the graphics are
hilariously bad,
but uh,
it's a good game.
It's a little slower.
The fast game was like quake one was
really fast,
too quick too,
is slower and then quake three became
more like quake one combination of quick
one quick to do.
It's pretty fast.
Quick us.
Perfect.
Miss it.
And you tried to play the new quake but
you didn't,
you didn't like it as much as that.
The only problem is it's fun.
We had a good time.
The only problem is you have to do
through their servers.
So it takes time.
It's got a load and it's like,
it's not.
I'm inpatient,
right motherfucking child.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you refused to try any of the other
ones,
right?
Like they're all just new addictions,
you know,
waiting to happen.
I just feel like if I got one addiction,
uh,
this weekend on Saturday,
they had a concert in fortnight.
Yeah,
marshmallow.
It was crazy.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
I think it's tough to explain what they
had.
It's called an event,
what they're calling it.
A second event.
So at 2:00 everybody showed up at the
game in this fucking concert started.
It was all the avatars were together,
like in one gigantic were normal mode,
you know,
you played at just like normal and then
all of a sudden like two minutes to go.
They took everybody's guns away and like
you all just sort of congregated around
the stage and the music started to show
started.
They started doing interactive things
with all the avatars and everything and
like 10 minutes later just it cut off,
but it turns out it was actually live.
He,
he was tweeting about it all day because
for promotion and whatnot.
But people were asking like,
how'd you do that?
How'd you work it out?
His voice was going live to everyone and
was playing.
It was probably millions of people and
it was just normal dj voice stuff like,
hey jump guys.
Hey,
what is it?
They were just like,
hey guys,
come on.
Like he wasn't interacting too much as
much as he probably does during a normal
set when he's playing to 20,000 people
in Vegas or whatever.
Yeah.
So when he does it,
he probably has like a really good
microphone to like,
it's not like the microphone that you
talk shit on,
right?
Yeah.
They had something else set up yet.
When we first started doing quick known
you had a type.
Yeah,
that's how goofy it was.
You to.
You couldn't talk shit.
Like now people are talking like they're
all in a group together talking shit.
Right.
I have a voice changer now too,
but doesn't have talking shit.
Get in the way.
Like if you hear people talking,
it gets in the way of hearing.
Sounds like sound cues.
Yes.
Yeah.
Tell your teammates shut the fuck up.
You can turn that off also.
Oh,
you can.
I like to hear the footsteps going
around coming around the corner and
stuff.
It's makes it scary.
Yeah.
It's part of what's scary about quake is
like you,
you hear someone running grow and you
know the right around the corner,
you can control all that.
It's all up to you.
Volume settings and all that kind of
very,
very addictive game.
So we should talk about this,
uh,
the Jack podcast because everybody got
so upset about it and let's clear up a
few things.
First of all,
the guy seems to be willing to talk
about anything.
It's not that I didn't want to talk to
about those things is just he was being
a,
I wouldn't say he's evasive,
but it was basically just saying what he
knew based on the company policy.
I didn't know what else more to ask him
and people felt like I didn't press him
hard enough and he to his credit,
reached out to me and said that he would
offer to do another one to ask more
questions.
That's cool.
I said that would be awesome.
So I said,
well,
this is the thing that people seem to be
upset about.
It seemed to be upset about very
specific cases where people showed.
I'm like,
if people were right wing and they were
posting things,
they were banned.
Whereas people who are left wing or
maybe people of different races or
allowed to post racist things or more
offensive things and even docs people
and didn't suffer any consequences for
it.
This is the argument,
my problem is I don't spend enough time
reading this stuff.
I don't know.
Like this is like when people get
banned.
Like Anthony Kumi is a friend of mine.
I don't really know why he got banned.
I don't know what happened.
There was that incident with that,
that woman that punched him and he ended
up getting fired.
He was drunk and he said a bunch of
really stupid shit on twitter and then
later apologized for it,
but I don't know if that's what got him
fired.
Kicked off twitter.
But he's my friend.
So what I'm saying is all these other
guys that have problems,
I don't know what the fuck happened,
man.
I'm busy.
I really don't.
I don't know.
I don't even know what got Alex Jones
kicked off,
which is why I asked him because that
was one of the last platforms for Alex
Jones was twitter,
but something got him kicked off their
take on it was it.
They never kicked him off before because
he didn't violate their terms of
service.
And another thing that's very
encouraging that Jack said,
and I know it's,
it's fun to get mad at things,
it's fun to get mad at him.
It's fun to get mad at me for it.
I get it.
I'd probably do the exact same thing.
I totally understand it,
but one of the things that he said was
that he believes that the ability to
communicate on the Internet through
twitter or through these platforms is a
basic human right.
That's how he looked.
Like I said,
do you think of it like a network like
NBC,
like if you're on NBC,
they can decide what's on and what's not
on,
or do you look at it like a utility?
And he specifically said that he looked
at it more like that,
that he thought it was a basic right.
That's very encouraging.
He also said that he would bring on
whoever it is in his team that's
responsible for these things so we could
hear from the actual person who decides
who's getting banned and why they're
getting banned and what is.
What's the decision making behind all of
these things.
So we can go over all of them.
I didn't think the podcast would create
such a controversy,
but that's probably poor prior planning
on my part because my thought about it
was,
hey,
I want a fucking crazy to be running
twitter.
Like it's crazy that this thing exists.
The president uses it as a platform.
I want to talk about the dude who
created this and what does this like to
have this thing evolve to become what
it's become because it didn't start out
that way.
It started out like fun shit like at
Brian red bands going to the movies,
you know what I mean?
Like that's what people used it for.
And then along the way became this
global method of distributing
information where people use it in war
zones,
man,
they use it to,
to tell people where attacks are the
user for all kinds of crazy shit.
It's like a,
it's a really powerful but strange
medium.
I didn't think about getting into the
weeds with all the very specific people
that got banned.
I just wanted to find out why they
banned people.
That was my take on it.
I know there's a lot of conservative
voices that have never been banned.
I don't think Steven crowder has been
banned.
I don't think Cernovich has been banned
as he'd been banned.
There's a bunch that have not been
banned.
Right.
So it's not like they banned all right
wing voices.
So what is it?
I don't know what it is.
I think it's what he said.
People reporting the tweet and then
somebody looking at it going,
well this does violate our policy and
maybe you know,
all these people that that got banned
violated the policy somehow.
You know,
it's probably as simple and clean as
that.
You know,
it's,
it's not that simple,
right?
Because they make their own policies and
it's also not that simple.
If people are allowed to say similar
things that are very racist in vast
generalizations about white people,
which seems to have been the case and at
least a few instances where people
reported that people said fucked up
things about white people,
but there was no repercussions.
And you know,
that's where the argument becomes.
These people are more oppressed and so
the white people were thought of as the
oppressor,
so you have this white privilege thing
that people love to use now as a reason
to to decide to like silence someone
like check your white privilege.
That's a.
that's an interesting thing that's
happening,
so if,
if there's this genuine movement where
people think that it's okay to say
things about one race,
whether you like it or not,
that's racism and if you're allowing
that from any one side and not allowing
it from another side,
it seems hypocritical.
Look,
it's very distasteful.
The idea of racism against black people
in this country is very distasteful to
everybody.
Almost everybody who's not a racist,
right?
Because of the history of this country,
because of slavery,
because of all these things.
It's a different connotation,
but if you just allow people to say
terrible things about any race,
it's racism.
You are allowing a,
like a predetermined attitude about a
race.
Some people have done this,
they have made generalizations,
generalizations,
a racist statements about white people.
The really weird thing that people are
thrown around these days is that you
can't be racist against white people
because racism is about power and
influence.
It's about using your.
You're in that black people are not
powerful to white people or power from
the white people were the ones who are
oppressed,
so it's impossible to be racist against
them.
That sounds like horse shit to me.
I'm not buying that.
That doesn't make any sense.
It's not beneficial to anybody to
generalize.
This is what we got to get it in our
head.
It doesn't matter if you're black or
you're white or if you're whatever the
fuck you.
It is not beneficial to generalize,
to take a person out of the group that
we think of as just human individuals
that you have to be an individual.
I mean,
I acknowledged the fact that people look
different.
They have different heritages as the
heritage.
Iss,
they have different,
different ancestry,
the different occupations.
There's different parts of the world.
There's all these differences,
but at the end of the day,
the only way we're all going to get true
equality and true kinship and comradery
as human beings is that if we recognize
we're just all a human being,
that's it.
There are very big differences in the
way we look and the things we like.
That's cool,
but as soon as you.
You can say shitty things about white
people or white men,
that leaves everybody who doesn't fit
that description guilty in this weird
way or presumed guilty because of a
racist statement.
That's all it is.
It's not good for anybody.
I get it that it's different than racism
against black people in America,
a country that was built essentially in
a lot of ways by slavery.
There's a war for slavery in this
country and that it is a crazy reality
that it's not your responsibility.
It's not mine.
I didn't do it.
You didn't do it,
but it's real.
Therefore,
as a person who's aware of his history,
the history of this country,
racism against white people seems
different,
but it still sucks to be racist against
a racist against black people.
Rather,
it seems different,
but it still sucks to be racist against
white people.
Sucks to be racist against Puerto
Ricans.
It's not good.
It's not good for anybody.
It's that's what we have to understand
about this social media thing.
What actually did happen and what is
happening,
why is it happening,
and if it's just some social justice
warrior ethic that you're not debating,
it doesn't seem fair.
It seems like there should be a
conversation about this and I bet
they're super reasonable,
really intelligent people and it's
possible they can come to a good place
that we can all agree to.
That is possible.
I'm not a cynical person.
I'm sorry.
I know a lot of folks who just want
those that just want the guests what
they already have it.
They have more money than they could
ever spend and my dealings with Jack as
a person,
he seems like a very nice guy and a very
smart guy and and a very empathetic guy.
I just think he's in a crazy
unmanageable situation to be running
something like twitter.
Yeah,
and there's probably people that did
something that they should have done in
terms of silencing people moving things
around.
It's probably happened.
It's a weird thing when people have
influence over people and there have
been videos had been proven.
We're executives from a bunch of
different social media corporations have
talked about how to silence certain
voices,
how to push down certain voices.
Um,
this is something that needs to be
discussed.
Like is this a policy as a whole?
Is it,
you know,
is it because you think you're pushing
the right message as soon as someone
thinks they're pushing the right message
but they don't have,
there's no debate about that,
right?
They just decide our way's the right way
and they're pushing this and there's a
radical opposition to that message from
half the country like that,
but usually like,
no,
but this is the one that's in control.
That narrative.
This is the one that's in control of
social media.
It's this far left leaning ideology and
the other part gets pushed aside.
That's a very bad situation for all of
us because there has to be conversation,
there has to be debate because if
there's not,
it's just shores up the differences
between two people and they fucking hate
each other even more.
I did not take that into account and I
fucked up.
That's my mistake.
That is my mistake when I made that
podcast,
but I didn't take it easy on them
because I didn't want to discuss those
issues.
I just didn't think enough of it in
advance.
I'm not as involved in it as other
people are.
I'm aware that there censorship and
social media.
I'm aware my.
My ideas going into that conversation
were more about how insane this method
is for distributing information for the
people that have been banned and for the
people that were fans of the people that
are banned.
I can understand whether it be upset at
me.
It has nothing to do with any
preconceived notions that I had is just
how the conversation took place,
so all it is,
and if you felt let down by that,
you didn't feel like it was an extensive
enough.
I'm more than willing to do it and go
further into it and we're going to and
Jack offered it and he's going to bring
someone else who's gonna explain things
to us.
I think this will be very beneficial for
everybody.
I also think that there should be a road
to redemption.
I think if you've got something that's
important as twitter or facebook or
instagram,
if you're not stealing someone stuff
like,
you know,
using copyrighted music or something on
an instagram page where you get banned
over and over again for doing it,
but you keep doing it.
If it's not something like that,
if it's,
uh,
an ideological difference.
If you maybe you crossed a line that
they,
they decided was align,
you should be able to work your way
back.
You the should.
There should be a way where you can sign
up again,
meaning,
like get a new email address.
I don't mean that I be the same person.
You should.
You should be able to be the same
person.
There should be a way where there should
be different levels.
Definitely everybody.
People fuck up,
man.
They fuck up.
And they make mistakes,
right?
And people also grow.
I mean there's this guy that was on Sam
Harris' podcast.
I'm Christian ecoline I think is his
name.
He was a fucking white supremacist,
a full on white supremacist and now he
is the exact opposite.
He's like this very progressive guy who
gives speeches on the dangers of racism
and that and the idle ideology,
how it caught up with him now if he got
banned when he was a young man and
making terrible decisions and then
became a better person.
Shouldn't we give it a guy like that?
A chance to get back in a platform?
Right?
And without making a whole new screen
name,
like maybe it would be.
And I don't think there's anything wrong
with the anonymous model.
There's some things that are really good
about it,
right?
Like people like Jack even talked about
this,
that people can report news stuff and
not worry about fear of retribution that
they can.
They can whistle blow and not worry
about fear of retribution if someone's
life is on the line,
but they're trying to provide a service
to the general public or they're trying
to give people information that maybe
might even save lives but could put them
at risk,
especially in like third world countries
or war torn countries.
That can be a huge problem if you have
to post,
you know Brian Red Band,
this is the only way you can get this
information out.
You have to use your whole name,
but it probably be better off for
everybody if people had a way of
communicating with each other like it's
just person to person and I think the
real problem is when people try to
engineer these conversations,
and this is another conversation about
youtube.
People have said that we're deleting
comments on Youtube.
We're not deleting anything.
We haven't deleted any comments.
I don't know how it works.
I don't read them.
I'm sure people say mean things.
Have a good time.
The thumbs up,
thumbs down thing.
Look,
we we,
we don't have to have that on there.
You don't have to have comments on their
youtube gives you the option to have
comments on and to have the thumbs up,
thumbs down.
I'm not taking those off.
He could have a good time with it,
but we're not fucking with that.
There's something that they're doing
that's not.
It's not.
I post at 3:41 and Jamie posts it 3:42
and this is the line of the comments.
It's not like that.
They've got their own way of doing it.
The question is why does youtube do it?
What's their what?
What are they trying to do is are they
trying to block out spam?
Are they trying to block out hate speech
or are they trying to engineer
conversation?
Talking about comment,
order comments on note,
comments disappear.
They go away.
A lot of times it's automatic.
If somebody flags a comment that just
take the comment away until it's like
looked over upon only one person.
Yeah,
on.
I think on youtube that that happens
quite often.
Probably be as little as one or two
people.
Yeah,
so that is probably what's happening to
all you folks that think your comments
are getting deleted.
No one's deleting shit.
Look,
I'm.
I'm not attached to what I do in the
sense that I'm unwilling to look at what
I do wrong.
I tried to look at everything that I do
wrong in concluding this,
so if you were upset of this podcast
because you thought somehow another I
sold out because I didn't ask him
anymore questions.
I just asked the questions I wanted to
ask.
I understand you have more costs,
more questions,
and I do too.
I have more questions too,
especially upon seeing people's reaction
to it and upon making myself pay more
attention to all these various stories.
Matt sent us a list of them.
Some of them are really fucking crazy.
There's some crazy things people have
said and not gotten in trouble for.
Whereas other people said things that
really weren't that bad and got in
trouble for it.
Why is that?
That's a good question to ask,
so we'll.
We'll concentrate on that.
We're just going to work out a date,
so my humblest apologies to all of you.
Don't not trying to let anybody down.
I always try to do my best.
That's it.
And,
and also here's another clear one.
No one tells me what to do.
There's no one,
there's no secret person behind the
scenes.
If I fuck up,
it's because of me.
It's my fuck up.
I should've prepared more.
I should have thought about it more,
but I didn't realize like how upset
people would be.
I think he did a great.
I thought it was a great interview and I
didn't even think of that.
I thought you kind of touched on it a
little when you were talking about Alex
Jones and I think that was like,
okay,
you know,
this is what happens.
Well,
it's a very specific group of people
that are upset.
Right wing guys is,
there's a lot of American flags,
a lot of pepe the frog.
It's all right.
People,
which look,
man easily could've been me at many
points in my life easily.
Especially being a troll online.
You know,
if you're working in some fucking job
and you make him pepe the frog memes and
you're fucking with people,
I get it.
It's one of the things I like about the
internet,
like I don't,
I don't want to be comfortable.
I'm like,
I don't,
I don't want to be comfortable all the
time I want.
I want a little bit of chaos.
I like the fact that there's people
like,
they're like that fucking.
I was upset that that radio,
that podcast,
they took it down where they were
fucking with Shiela bu with those guys
from four Chan and the way they took it
down was they contacted radio lab and
said those guys are white supremacists
and they support white supremacy.
You know,
and then you just,
you know,
you made these people that are awful,
terrible people that write terrible
things.
You,
you,
you gave them props.
But the thing about something like four
Chan is no,
you might read some terrible things,
but you've got to realize you're also
reading terrible things from anonymous
people that are working at their jobs
most of the time and they're trying to
fuck with people's heads and the trying
to get people upset.
They're there.
They're having a good time fucking with
people if you want to take them as that,
that's like them,
like giving,
giving a talk to a dear friend or them
giving you an affidavit in court.
Well,
you're missing the whole thing.
It's entertainment like half of the
whole reason why they're doing it is
entertainment.
They didn't go steal shiela booze flag
and go and go right into the camera and
go fuck Shiela.
Bu By using coordinates from photographs
of the sky where they figured out where
the fucking with the constellations lie
and then drove around honking their horn
so that they could locate where it was
by using the Webcam and listening to how
close they got to it.
I mean it's fucking genius shit and it
got taken down just by this accusation
of them being racist.
But the thing about a forum like four
Chan or Reddit or anything,
you have so many fucking people.
You have 3000 and thousands and
thousands of people.
If you have 10 clients posting jokes
about black people,
that's all you need to ruin the
reputation of thousands of people.
So for someone to say that everybody
that was like,
fuck Shiela,
Bu is some racist and the white
supremacist,
that's a cheap way out.
That's a cheap way out.
I bet.
More likely it's some duties board and
he's sitting in front of his fucking
computer and he works all day and this
is where he escapes.
He escapes and types in writes things.
Then check some later and then it goes
back to and type thing and checks and it
keeps him sane and the stupid fucking
cubicle.
That's a lot of the people.
So they pulled that whole amazing
podcast down because of that.
Look what He.
The Shiloh booth thing was ridiculous.
He will not divide us.
Come on,
stop.
Stop.
We get a chance at everywhere.
It's funny what they did.
They mocked something that's their way
of mocking it.
Nobody got hurt.
They made it out like it was really
awful crime.
They committed on this.
This amazing person who's just trying to
change the world.
No,
no.
They prank Ceaila Boo.
And they said,
fuck Shiela bu this is that as of the
above,
whatever it is.
Shiela buff special.
He's a nice guy too.
He probably did something silly.
It's a little silly.
He will not divide us.
What they.
What they did was funny.
It's a funny reaction.
I.
I liked that.
I like that this is an important part of
this thing.
If it wasn't for people like that,
there would be no podcast.
Now the like to dislike ratio that you
see on youtube videos is fascinating,
right?
Because it's weaponized and they're
thinking about trying to ban that now
because so many people use it to fuck
with people.
I hate to say this about you folks,
but every time we have a chicken here,
they get fucking torture.
The like to dislike,
right?
Like it's ruthless.
Except Rhonda.
Patrick said
Rhonda Patrick,
but it's just like it's weaponized.
It's the.
They're just going to dislike it
because.
Because it's fun because it's fun
because it's fun.
It's also fun to throw a rock at a
window.
It's fun.
Yeah.
Some of them probably didn't even watch
the podcasts like thumbs down gives them
a disliking.
It gives a little bit of power and the
algorithm ofd ranking.
It affected something and people who
liked it,
there's a probably a lot of them that
didn't even watch it.
There's a button you can press.
People are weird,
you know,
but it's clearly it shows by the amount
of dislike.
The people moved on it and they were
upset about it.
So it's basically it.
We'll see.
There's a lot of cool,
interesting questions that to ask him.
Like I always thought shadow banning was
a real thing,
but I think he came out and said that
that's not a real thing.
I've,
I've seen it in my,
in person where I'll type
somebody's name in and usually it's
splits to come up on the searches,
but it doesn't in our
planning is if it is a real thing,
like that's another one,
like shadow banning for what?
Like if it,
if it's not something that is.
If you're not doing something that you
could get kicked off the platform for
it.
Right.
You're not kicking them off,
you just pushing them down.
Weird place.
But if you're doing that,
like why are you doing that?
Like what?
Because like,
but what would be the justification from
the ones that I have seen three used to
even be a website that you could type in
somebody's user name to see if there are
shadow bands,
so that's kind of interesting,
but a lot of porn stars or shadow banned
because they don't want.
If you're looking up Christina
applegate,
they want Christina,
you know,
apple bottom or something like that.
You know what I mean?
So it's,
it's,
I,
I still believe that's a thing,
but I'm pretty sure he came out and said
it wasn't a real thing.
Technically shadow banning Justin Bieber
from the trending topics.
Right.
I mean they have publicly said that
that's not a shadow ban.
That's a strategy.
Well,
no,
they were kind of forced into it because
Justin Bieber was so.
His fans trend so hard.
They hashtag the shit out of that thing
and they just took over the trending.
That's probably happening for other
equally popular celebrities too,
like Taylor swift's and beyond time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're probably right.
So whatever they're doing at youtube
with comments and whatever they're doing
with twitter,
here's the real conversation,
right?
The real conversation is,
do we want that?
Do we want them to cure rate?
Do we want them to decide whose youtube
videos you can subscribe to and who do
they unsubscribe people?
Is that real or is that a glitch?
I.
Yeah.
Who knows?
I don't think they unsubscribe.
I don't think so either,
but people have.
Well,
let's listen.
If they're willing to move justin bieber
from the number one trending because
he'd number one trends too hard and they
think it's ridiculous.
Not to just acknowledge that our
culture,
there's certain humans in our culture,
we're spending an exorbitant amount of
time thinking about that.
Beautiful Man,
right?
There's a lot,
but why do we want to lie and pretend
that it's not as big.
So if they just.
I'm not saying they shouldn't,
but if they did that just.
If they did that,
you go,
okay,
are we through the looking glass?
Now you can change the data.
Like what?
What do you lend?
When do you decide who gets pushed here?
Who gets pushed there
side?
Definitely the trending page on youtube
is 100 percent controlled by a human.
I don't know if they've said that,
but there are videos that should be
there that aren't based off of the data.
You see Youtube has got some weird
things going on with it.
Like there's a.
The video is that they go,
you might like type thing.
They did it.
You might like to me a couple months ago
where it was just videos of a guy towing
cars in dallas like out of their parking
lot and he made these funny cute little
videos with a little commentary using
videos from the security cameras.
Anyways,
I don't know why I it,
but I started watching it and I was
like,
you know,
this is interesting.
So I tweeted it out like random video I
just got addicted to on Youtube.
Everybody was like hundreds of people
who are like,
I just started watching that.
Youtube recommended that to me.
Like how did that happen?
You know,
this little guy with a tow truck company
has now pushed on everybody's laps and
now he just went over 100,000
subscribers the other day and it was
like months ago that he was just had
like 10 that,
that.
That's the argument some people have
made that that's how fast the Paul
brothers,
they grew and they grew so fast on
youtube that some people thought there
was something up that game like millions
of followers within a week or two of
being on there and then they were coming
from another platform.
Well it's also coming from another
platform is giant,
but it's also all it really takes is one
person deciding that whatever the fuck
you did was funny or weird or crazy.
Like that cashew outside girl.
Yeah.
Well there's that girls are managed by
the same people that own tmz and that's
why you see it on tmz every.
I was going to bring up,
if you want to fire the fire festival
documentary,
there's a,
an explanation of this show.
How this,
uh,
they spread of the Fuck Jerry guys,
the marketing team spread that with the
orange picture.
It was a coordinated event over hundreds
of different social media accounts for
her,
for the cash me outside girl.
For the FYRE festival.
Yeah.
Firefox to catch everybody's.
Because there are a team of people.
There are agencies that have all this
influence or accounts.
They paid them.
They don't have to accept the money or
accept the offer except the campaign,
but oftentimes they do.
So it's like a talent agency.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I don't need to share a new person,
you know,
launch the next,
the next voice,
and it's like,
oh,
here's a new song.
There's a new movie.
It's just a new way to suppress stuff.
It's pretty cool watching how many
people are unsubscribing to fuck Jerry
and the fat Jew though.
That's.
But are they?
I looked at the other day was the day of
like $14 million.
500,000 dollars a week.
Weekend real estate,
a significant amount of time.
I was 14 point seven then it was 14
point one.
Haven't looked today,
but that's coming from I think of video.
Someone to shared this week.
I think vic Berger made a video that got
spread around and they took his video.
Right.
I,
maybe that's what he said.
I think I saw it on burgers page.
Here's a few comics I've posted videos
like,
hey,
you know,
fat Jews stole this,
and I tried to reach out and they never
got back to me.
He got 10 million.
What do you think about this idea
though?
Like that's kind of piracy,
you know?
And so instagram's allowing twitter's
allowing piracy.
Well I think they're allowing these
people to post videos because you don't
really know where it came from.
There's no proof.
Right?
Like if you find a meme,
like how many times he posted a Meme,
I pee,
I repost whoever sent it to me.
If someone sends it to me,
but sometimes I'll just find it in a
google search and you've got to figure
out who made that meme and if I find
their instagram account that I'll try to
find it and repost it,
but some people don't and I haven't in
the past.
Like I did that one with a baked Alaska
got mad at me because there was one with
Alex Jones sitting in hot tub
and it's uh,
it's like when your friends are trying
to chill and,
but you have to keep dropping truth
bombs.
It was hilarious.
I didn't know it was his right.
I just posted it because someone said to
me,
someone sent it to me in a text message,
I think.
But those things have a creator.
Right.
And I know Pete,
like Eddie Bravo makes his own.
He makes them sometimes,
but he'll send some to me or post some
online that he finds that are funny too.
And everybody tries to credit the person
who did it right.
But now what they do is they,
they take it and they credit the person,
but they didn't
for so long.
They only attempt.
They're accrediting fake accounts.
So they'll make,
they have.
So they're not getting busted in the
way.
You're just explaining.
I've seen that too.
Well,
what is that about though?
Because that seems like deception.
It's just the way around the back door
and that that qualification of it needs
to be on an account.
We need to point to somebody,
okay,
well we'll point to this account,
but it's not even a real account and if
they find like they'll post stuff and
then later add the person because the
person contacts them and they're almost
like that's admitting to piracy like we
did hire because if they just reposting
it,
a lot of folks including me do that.
Yeah,
but they're making the person making
money or not.
Yeah,
that's important.
I don't make any money off my instagram.
Right.
They're making millions.
I've been offered to post stuff up and
I'm not saying that I wouldn't.
If something was fucking killer and they
wanted to give me money,
I'm greedy.
I'll take some money,
but it wouldn't lie about it.
I haven't yet.
I've never accepted any money yet.
Yeah,
because it's also,
I think in instagram's a law that you
have to put that it's an ad if you're
making money off of it and so that's
another thing that both fuck Jerry and
fat Jew or not doing.
They're not putting the cad is.
I just wanted like to devil's advocate
this though is is there a place for them
for those accounts?
Like is there a place to be the re
tweeter have the means to be that guy to
be that account,
you know,
like isn't that valuable source?
It is a curator position.
Yeah.
It's kind of valuable.
But the question is like if it,
if it is valuable and it becomes
something almost like redistributing
your standup.
If you're doing a set,
like if standup sets where you know
something that you just,
you could get everywhere and you could
just repost it on your page but then
your page becomes super popular because
you are all these people stand up sets.
You know like spotify,
spotify gets ads right?
But they don't really.
They pay the artists a little bit,
but mostly they make all the money.
Yeah.
And you know like if it's,
you use like say sorry later,
you just do it and say I'm sorry,
we'll figure it out after the fact.
Or you figure it out.
Business oriented things that have art
in them as opposed to art
oriented,
things that start making money.
There are two very different things,
so this is not an art thing.
This is a.
They find other people's art and they
sell it.
They're pushing it,
they create these accounts.
The accounts get giant.
People pass it around because they're
just finding funny things and then they
start profiting,
but all the people that created all the
intellectual property gets zero money.
Which is weird.
I don't remember,
but I only learned more about this when
exit through the gift shop came out.
Isn't that what Andy Warhol sort of did?
I don't know and I don't care.
I mean maybe he did.
Maybe he did,
but the thing about it is that this is
happening right now on the Internet.
It's a totally different animal.
I mean,
Andy Warhol wasn't running around taking
exact photo duplicates and putting them
on his website for sale like these.
This is when someone's doing on an
instagram page is like you could within
seconds take a piece and put it
somewhere else.
It's seconds.
Brian posts something.
I think it's funny.
Ha,
I go to copy,
I go to the fucking repost at a APP,
I put it in there,
I'll repost it.
It's seconds later.
You could do that all day and if you
hire kids,
I don't know if he has people working
for them,
but if these guys do,
they hire people for fucking 20 bucks an
hour or whatever and these people just
do it all day long.
They just find funny shit all day long.
They look for certain hashtags.
Meme factories or what they're calling.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And there's some people like,
you know,
that have made some funny ones all their
own,
you know,
a lot of people that are just doing that
all.
I know Dalea has done a bunch of them
and then there's also one that they do
where they steal people's act and make a
meme out of it and then posted it on
their page.
That's where it gets even more slippery
because you're talking about like
standups acts that you're,
you're making money off it.
How much are they making off each post?
I mean,
I don't know,
but these are multimillion dollar
business and the punchline,
so now you have this 10 minute joke that
everyone has the punchline because they
saw it on facebook.
That's like,
spoiler alert one for sure if you're
still doing that material because it
wasn't on Netflix or a comedy central
special or something.
For sure.
That sucks.
I guess it's always happened though,
hasn't it?
TV shows have been accused of stealing a
stolen.
It's happened on.
Do they did it to Kevin James?
I saw it happen.
Kevin James was at the uh,
he had a development deal for NBC back
in the,
a back when we were young pups.
Both of us were like 27 or some shit.
Maybe he's a little older than that.
Maybe it was actually,
that was like during the news radio
days,
so we're probably like in our thirties
and he had this development deal,
nice development deal.
They're paying them a lot,
a lot of gas,
a lot of paper and they were setting up
a sitcom around him.
So they had him do a set at a theater in
Hollywood and I was there.
And he does this set and has all these
writers from various sitcoms and the
very next season,
one of his best jokes is on an episode
of a television show that's very
popular.
Very popular.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And uh,
they fucking stole his bitmap.
I guess that's where I was going because
that was in the nineties.
So like we're now 25,
20,
25 years later.
The popular medium
is instagram and social media different
is that.
Well,
it's different because there's
accountability now because now people
know that if you wrote a meme and you
put it up on your site and then fuck
jerry comes along and steals your shit
and doesn't credit you for it,
just puts it up there.
You know what they did,
unless someone sent it to them and
didn't attribute it to you,
which is possible,
but it seems much more likely that what
they're doing,
they were doing on purpose for the
longest time.
And they just did.
They thought that's what you could do on
the Internet.
It's a wild west.
You could just take memes and you can
become famous and looked at fat Jewish
guy,
did it.
I mean that guy became famous.
What whether you agree with his methods
or not.
It worked.
He got his crazy hair.
He shows you,
you know,
like he's just crazy looking guy and he
has all these funny memes that somebody
else wrote and they're all up on his
instagram page and it worked and people
don't like him.
Now there's a lot of people that don't
like him.
People will get real shitty with them in
person.
They don't want them to do an appearance
because they know what he did.
So there's a certain number of people
that go,
hey man,
you're a thief.
Like this is not cool.
Like what you did is not cool.
But then there's certain people that
don't care and then there's certain
people that think,
well,
what he did was just what anybody did
back then.
It was the wild west.
No one thought about it and once he
established that business model and it
was effective,
it was probably very hard for him to
slow it down or to attribute things to
people or to admit that he didn't do it
for all.
That amount of time
just bugs me that companies pay these
guys knowing that they do this or like
as a Jew,
he's like,
see,
he's signed with caa who's signed with a
bunch of comedians they probably took,
you know,
they're taken from the same basket.
So it's like,
it is weird,
right?
Yeah.
Now if he was going on stage and doing
their acts,
she's been doing appearances.
Right.
He's got a book.
He's been on TV shows.
Well,
I don't know.
I don't know what he's doing.
He's doing by maybe showing up,
but he's.
Look,
he's obviously used it for profit.
He's figured out a way to profit.
It's weird.
He must be weirded out by this fuck
jerry thing too,
because you might be.
Must be sitting there going,
okay,
all right,
here was going to leave me alone.
It's,
um,
you know,
comedy central was advertising on the
fuck Jerry page,
which is like Jesus folks.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
It was like Jesus folks,
can I just sit you guys down?
Go over a little history.
Sure.
Comedy.
Well,
I mean it might've been car.
They didn't learn that either,
you know.
Well that was while it was happening,
you know,
they,
they did learn eventually they let it go
eventually.
But that was also because the ratings
have dropped through the floor or
you know,
comedies on fucking easy to make up,
especially like meme kind of comedy
that's done by folks that are working in
offices,
meme kind of comedy,
some of the funniest fucking comedy on
earth.
And it's done by regular people.
It's not like a,
it sound like most
memes are written by high level
satirists that worked for the New
Yorker.
No,
they're fucking regular folks who think
something's funny.
You know,
I think what's going to happen is that
as technology improves,
the like being able to scan a photo and
go,
well we could tell the first time this
was ever put on the Internet with from
this little girl,
she took a photo of it has all the data
in the picture and that's now used on
this mean that's making this much money
in this game.
Then it's gonna be kind of broken down
like a,
you know,
any kind of artists.
Yes,
yes.
I mean the idea for the buyer and the
argument for the block chain getting
involved in here because we could tie
that.
You can,
I guess it can be in the data and the
bins like.
No.
Let me ask you this.
What if someone uses a picture of your
band,
so you have a band,
they use a picture of your band and then
they have a funny meme under the picture
of your band who owns that?
Then that's what like,
I think beyonce tried to get that
picture taken off the Internet from her
from the super bowl a couple years ago
because it was like a bad picture.
She didn't like how she looked in it.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
That's how the fuck is that lady to take
a bad picture.
I just,
she doesn't talk to her.
Go listen.
It's good.
It's not your best,
but you look fucking great.
Like if that shit was on tinder,
you know,
you wouldn't be on like did it?
Who?
If someone was paying for that meme
should be onstage gets some of the money
or that's.
That's the question you would have with
like a corporation.
Right?
Which should someone be able to grab
photos that are out in the public
domain,
make something with it and then
profiting.
That's the,
that's.
There's been a lot of bands.
I'm sure that that's why I said bands
because they're like really good at
protecting copyright and their logo and
shit.
If you had like the kiss band logo,
you don't think gene Simmons would come
at you.
He's coming at you with some lawyers,
100 percent,
right.
That's just what he's going to do,
but it's who owns those photos?
If it's like Gene Simmons,
like spitting fire out and I think if
you took the photo and the cameras were
allowed inside the event you took it,
but it's not for what the cases though.
Most of the photographs or people that
are putting out there,
just putting them up online and someone
takes it.
It's like say if you gene simmons
spitting fire and then it has a joke
about eating hookers,
pussy or something like whatever it is.
Like make something funny there.
If that's online and that becomes this
giant meme that gets all these likes and
that somehow or another someone,
how the fuck do you profit from you?
From instagram?
You don't profit from individual posts,
but those individual posts will boost
your signal.
Yeah.
Some posts are profit.
Instagram,
you have to say add on it to say
sponsored post,
right?
Yeah.
What legally exposed to,
but I'd probably say 90 percent of them
aren't.
Right.
A lot of people don't write,
especially if it's like instagram is you
can get away with it.
Instagram models talking about t I e s
t,
eh?
Yeah.
It's a whole instagram model is a
fucking hilarious position.
It really is.
Powerful position.
Yeah.
It's hilarious though.
It's,
it's amazing how many of them there are
and they make money.
No,
it's smart.
It's amazing how butts are such a big
thing now.
Yeah.
And like when I was a kid that no one
cared about butts.
It was big.
But you're like,
Ooh,
listen,
wait.
Yeah.
We talked about this before
when I said let's start mixed a lot of
change the game and everybody's like,
oh you like big butts.
Hey,
I kinda like for whatever reason,
it wasn't even an issue back then.
Girls would have giant fake boobs and
tiny flat butts and they were perfect.
My grandmother would have millions of
instagram model hits.
Fat bottom girls was before that
slightly,
but no one really.
It didn't make the rock world go round.
That's a great God damn song.
I didn't see Bohemian rhapsody.
Did you?
Did you see it?
I heard it wasn't that good.
What the fuck are you guys talking
about?
I heard it was amazing.
Did you?
Yeah,
I did.
I'm a giant queen fan though.
I love them.
That's my number one cryogenic song when
I'm in the crowd chambers dragging
attack to do
because you got to move around when
you're in that 240 degrees below zero.
It's hard to just sit.
Still do a little dancing in there.
Uh,
he did a rainy Malik,
I think is the,
the actor's name that played him Freddy
Mercury.
Oh,
good job.
But before it happened,
Sacha Baron Cohen was sort of in talks
for it,
but you wanted to take the character in
a different direction that no one was
really comfortable with it.
I would've rather have seen that.
No Man.
What does that mean?
That's a weird thing,
man.
You can't because it's been said to that
get spicy talk,
but you can't just add stuff.
My wife
an art piece like Bohemian rhapsody,
although it is an art piece,
it's a documentary of a guy's life.
Like in some ways you're documenting it
right?
Like it's supposed to be his life,
you can't make up things that never
really happened or I forget what movie,
but it's like a,
it's the difference between like a bio
pic and an actual biography or
documentary.
Like what is the difference you're
making a Hollywood movie versus.
But what is the difference in terms of
the story creative?
I think creative control.
I like being creative with some.
Like we know this event happened in this
event,
happened that day before and in the
middle.
What would happen where one one is
knowing all the facts,
the foxcatcher versus a documentary
about Mark Schultz parts in there that
you specifically know.
Yes,
we're fucked with for no resistance
sake.
Not just the parts that I know,
but I didn't even talk to mark about the
movie,
but there was a bunch of parts that I
think he was furious about where it made
it look like they were doing blow and
maybe doing some gay stuff.
It looked,
it was,
uh,
there was a lot of weird scenes that
things were implied or just seemed odd.
Like,
how do you know this happened in less
mark told you?
And so,
and mark was furious at the end,
uh,
after it was released.
And then on top of that,
I like the big one was that they changed
his opponent when he fought in the UFC.
They gave him a Russian guy when he in
fact fought big daddy
goodrich who's a legend,
like big daddy goodrich's an MMA legend.
He was a pioneer.
He was in the early UFC,
the giant yoked black dude with the
Geeky.
I mean he would fight with the guy.
He has one of the most brutal knockouts
in the history of the sport where he
fought this wrestle.
Paul Herrera and Paul took him down and
they got into a position where a big
daddy goodrich was lying on him sideways
and he elbowed him in the face like 10
times in the course of like three
seconds.
And it's so horrific.
You watching his head just bounce off
before they stopped the fight.
It's fucking brutal.
Like one of the most brutal Kales you'll
ever see in your life.
So this guy wasn't a just a regular guy
like you just substitute them out and
make the guys named Tom Instead of Bob.
No,
it was big daddy goodrich.
That's who mark Schultz fought when he
fought in the UFC.
Watch this,
watch this.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
I mean that guy is cop out and his arms
are trapped in his legs.
A trap.
Big Daddy's got him in like a,
a like a crucifix position and it's from
Paul tried to take him down.
I mean that was a.
So that guy,
big daddy goodrich is a.
he's a famous fighter.
It's not like they took some nobody and
removed him from the movie and changed
the name of someone where it was.
It didn't really matter.
It was a historical event in mma.
That's the reason anything.
No one knows.
Some crazy producer.
I think you should fight the Russian guy
because this is.
We're in the cold war again baby.
I don't know.
You boot and I don't know how you feel
about politics and some producer.
Just one of the judges on the soup.
Some writer just wanted to cup his own
balls,
squirt one off into the fucking stew.
That's probably what happened.
Yeah,
the screenplay to make it to watch
better.
Who knows?
The only other thing that makes sense is
maybe they would've had to pay get daddy
goodrich.
Right.
And they didn't want to pay him.
Maybe.
I don't know if that makes sense.
That makes sense.
I mean like Mike Tyson,
you know,
he had that video game a long time ago
with Nintendo and they had to pay him to
use Mike Tyson's punch in,
punch out and then after like a couple
of years he was like,
I hadn't done like this in.
So now it didn't.
It was just called punch out.
It wasn't even Mike Tyson in the game
anymore day.
Like take it off.
Some new dude.
Yeah.
Have you done the Vr boxing game yet?
I haven't done the Vr boxing game,
but it looks cool.
Like the rocky one.
Is that what it is,
is a whole bunch.
A whole bunch of them too.
They're amazing.
Yeah.
It's like a regular boxing game.
You playing on TV is so stupid.
I mean they're fun,
but in comparison to a vr game,
in a Vr game,
you're boxing,
you're,
you see your hands in front of you,
the guy's throwing jabs,
you're slipping,
you're like standing in front of them.
You can catch punches with your hands,
you can throw shots to the body.
It's crazy.
You get tired doing it.
Like you could really get a workout
doing it.
It's amazing.
And this is it right here.
Like this,
what you had sent us,
the new rocky when they just updated
clubber Lang.
Mr. T's in it or is it just random guy
with Mohawk?
Well,
that's clubber Lang.
But look,
look how everybody is.
Imagine if people were really that Jack
Town.
I mean this is.
So what does that Drago and he's
fighting.
There's drago versus rocky.
Yeah.
But we can't see.
You want to see what it looks like from
your eyes.
And this is a,
um,
that's a regular video game or that is
just for testing of the.
And this is just a teaser that showed.
I guess I was looking for the updated.
You want to see what it looks like when
you've got those gloves in front of you.
Have you tried Vr pull yet?
No.
No,
no.
I like regular pool.
Vr are so great.
I love it.
I just need to get it out of my living
room.
It's just too much for my living.
There's things that you couldn't do with
Vr pool that you need to understand.
If you're actually playing pool with
real pool,
you need friction.
Wow.
This looks great.
It's crazy because it looks nice.
It looks a little bit of haptic feedback
for this to get maybe the next step to
look how he's using his hands to block
too crazy.
The thing is,
man,
when when someone swinging on you,
when this fake person in front of his
friends,
it's nerve wracking.
You think you're going to get hit and
when you do get hit and you see red
where you see white rather,
you just killed them.
It's funny watching the guy.
It's pretty amazing how vr really gets
immersive like where you were like the
resident evil video game.
I mean,
that's scary as fuck.
You really think zombies are coming
after you.
You.
Yeah.
You really do.
You know that game.
The thing about that game though,
it doesn't necessarily.
Boxing thing does not necessarily reward
perfect technique.
It's just you could kind of just do this
and do that.
So you'd have to like be.
If you wanted to use it as a workout,
you'd have to actually be disciplined
and use good technique.
Well you'd probably do is put gloves on,
put some velcro gloves on and put the,
the,
the little fucking hand thing glove
close to.
They're better than the next year.
Two.
You can just duck tape it year or two.
It'll be in the glove itself.
Yeah,
there's actually a,
I think it's called the knuckle
controller is the next version of the
vive controller.
It fits around your hand like a glove.
It's not just goes around your neck if
you don't have to grab sort of in the
same way.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause um,
when you have your hands this way,
like with thumbs up,
thumbs up shows the gloves like this on
the screen for some strange reason.
So when you're throwing punches,
it doesn't look right,
they need to change that,
but other,
because they,
it's like they want you to just do this,
but that's freaking me out.
But when you're actually doing it
though,
if it looked like your hands in the same
position as your hands,
it would be a worthwhile way to learn.
Like a guy like Freddy Roach could
literally do a game where he showed you,
all right,
I want to see the gap right here,
right here,
right pop.
And then here comes the hook,
duck under,
and then we'll go to the body,
go to the head,
and you could do that and do drills
with a guy.
And actually you could pick up real
skills in a vr game,
especially with boxing,
boxing,
particularly kickboxing,
maybe a little less because you're
moving your legs,
you're not just moving your hands,
like you'd have to have some sort of
sensors on your legs so I can know what
you're doing to make sure you're not
showing bad technique.
Like your knee might be down or you
might be doing something funky.
But if you have boxing,
those two things are just like gloves,
all you need to learn as all the other
things you need to learn how to punch it
out and move around,
but you can effectively with just
holding onto those things,
you're,
you're staying in the same position that
you would be if you were really boxing
and you can move around the ring too.
Like it's a,
it's an area like the size of this desk
maybe like a little bit more so it's not
like you're in one place and you don't
have footwork.
You could actually develop footwork too,
so they can have like a facility Loma
Chanko doing like footwell drills,
footwork drills rather where you would
learn on a virtual reality thing,
where to step,
that'd be fucking bad ass.
All that stuff that you could learn some
shit from those things.
I like how the Vr is.
There's an amusement park or a buildings
now,
kind of like chuck e cheese where it's
just vr rides now we're just like,
oh,
you're a parachuting or you're on a
rollercoaster and stuff.
I like how they're doing that now.
A lot of malls have that
now.
Yeah.
I've done those.
I've done the little spaceship ones too.
When you roll a Dune buggy around on the
surface of that.
Have you done the star wars one in Vegas
yet?
I guess you actually have like five
people in your group that you can see in
the game and there's like a,
you know.
Have you played at the Glendale
Galleria?
They do,
yeah.
Do the dopest one they have.
Is that the Disney land?
The same Disneyland village,
but the Disneyland village one is.
There's a start star wars one and then
there's also a wreck it Ralph one.
The record.
Ralph one is fucking amazing.
Is the same company avoid?
Well yeah,
that's it.
Same place.
So they have the star wars one
sometimes,
so they'll have like one game set up for
like a couple of weeks and then they'll
have the other game.
We went to Disneyland and that was the
dopest thing.
It didn't really.
Yes.
By far.
Fucking amazing dude.
You wear the suit.
Okay.
So you have this vest on,
so you're feeling when you get hit,
you feel in your chest,
you feel heat.
They have moved places where you walk
through and it's like lava below you.
You feel he was the star wars one.
When you're getting shot,
you feel it in your chest.
No Shit.
You pick the gun up off the wall and
you've got like storm trooper arms.
You see you're holding the gun in front
of you.
It's crazy.
Awesome.
I didn't know that was in Glendale do.
They're getting so good.
This still.
You still are super aware that you're in
a game for now.
But this,
you know,
go from Pong to fucking what's the best
red dead redemption.
That's probably the best graphics.
I mean fucking insane graphics.
That's what does that 30 years,
30 years they went to that these virtual
reality games,
10 years from now are going to be
insane.
No one's gonna want be in regular life.
Regular life's going to suck.
Yeah.
There's not going to be at Disneyland or
Disney world anymore.
It's just going to be vr.
It'll still be there,
but you'll be able to get on every ride.
I haven't watched this myself yet,
but the MBA makes a viewing and vr
available now.
Not every game,
but it's like once a week they have a
particular game you can.
You can log in and watch that.
They changed the cameras a little bit.
I don't think it's perfect yet.
Holy Shit.
Very cool though,
Dude.
Like watching this on the floor.
You're on the floor and they'll.
But they'll move you around so you can
sear in the footage to it.
I think they have a separate announcing
team,
so they're.
They're talking about what you're seeing
versus like listening to the normal TV.
Quite not there yet.
We filmed a couple episodes of kill Tony
and Vr and we had some of the top of the
line cameras for it and still wasn't
there yet.
It was more hassle than it was worth.
This seems like something that would be
fucking amazing for the UFC though.
Oh yeah.
I mean this would be a major basically
have your view.
Yeah,
except you.
The cage.
The cage would be in the way,
but there's gotta be a way that they
could film through the cage if they just
had a camera in a reinforced position
where it was far enough back behind foam
that there's no way it could interfere
if someone crashed into it but yet close
enough that it could see through an
actual hole.
You could get the entire octagon if you
did it with several.
Several different ones.
Are those
they had or they had it at least at
this,
isn't it?
I guess,
but it was a ground level.
I think they call it the Phantom Cam,
but maybe it had a different name and it
was vr.
It wasn't vr.
Know the UFC is used it a few times.
They always try out things there.
They're very experimental.
They don't always show everything
they're trying out though.
But problem with.
Cool to try.
Maybe one time.
Ideally you'd want it right in the
middle.
Like not above or two below.
Okay.
And it would have to have because it has
cameras all around it.
So
you know.
Now that's hard to do with the cameras.
I guess a without getting in the way,
if everything.
Yeah,
you'd have to.
You'd have to find a good spot for it,
put it on a burst buffers head and let
him just go to town.
Well,
they used to do that with pride.
Pride used to have like they would wear
glasses with like cameras next to the
glasses and you'd get the referee
vision.
Yeah.
It was crazy.
It's cool separating fighters and
breaking it up and waving the fight off.
Yeah,
that's Kinda cool.
it's pretty bad ass.
Yeah,
it is.
It's A.
I guess it's just a little team.
Marshall camp is what?
It's going Pov Cam,
but that's just point at me,
man.
Sometimes.
Yeah.
There's one like that that's pointed at
me.
Oh yeah.
I guess.
Sure.
I have seen that there.
Yeah,
they use that sometimes when you know,
when we go crazy when we jump up fights
happening.
I didn't know that was even.
I didn't know that's what they did it
for until one day I saw online.
I go,
oh,
that makes sense.
That's a smart thing to do because
sometimes we do get animated.
There's been several fights were me,
anik and DC or dominick Cruz.
We're all standing up like,
well,
while the like the end,
like Amanda Nunez when Amanda Nunez
knocked out Cris Cyborg,
we just,
we were like,
what?
Like your whole body is like,
she's us.
What the fuck did I just say?
Sometimes you just can't sit down.
You just,
your buys just like God damn it.
It just goes.
You don't,
you're not even trying to control it and
you just let it go.
When you see somebody do something
fucking insane.
Like there's some wild crazy francis in
Ghana knocking out Alistair overeem type
punch.
Yeah.
It's me and Dominic and John Eck and
annex up and I'm leaning back.
It's crazy job,
man.
It's crazy job.
So that was the moment.
And you see the one below it.
See that?
Go back to that.
So that one below it where I'm staring
at the camera in the upper right.
I know that froze up video taken by John
Wayne.
Par.
John Wayne Parr who is a multiple time
world champion and friend of mine,
a great guy who lives in Australia,
was there at the fights in Australia
when Holly Holm knocked out Ronda Rousey
and he filmed Holly Holm head kicking
Ronda Rousey and then turns to me and I
turned to him and I was like,
what the fuck just happened?
I was like,
Whoa,
whoa.
But when you see it,
like in that moment when you see,
when you see something that,
that fucking nuts in that moment,
you're like,
oh,
I can't even believe what I saw.
That was mailer.
I looked at him and he looked at me and
were like,
Whoa,
dude.
That was crazy.
There's no sport like that.
Some sports just,
you know,
they just have this moment where
everybody gets a jolt of a drug.
You know?
Everybody just gets it.
I mean,
that didn't happen last night at the
Super Bowl for you.
I left before it ended.
I was at a friend's party,
went to a superbowl party.
It was fun.
The lowest viewed one in the last 10
years.
Are you serious?
But not by a lot,
but yeah,
it's because they knew that that
handsome man was going to take your
shirt off.
Oh Levine.
It's beautiful man.
No nipples,
nipples.
Now he has a Nice Brown Nicholas.
But then we're like Janet Jackson,
like the big crazy.
Why is he loved shows nipples.
So both.
This is bullshit,
sexist bullshit.
And his Dick Route.
This is.
Oh my God.
He had decreased showing God is
bullshit.
He just wanted.
Everybody knows he's got beautiful
tattoos and a fairly good body.
Doesn't move.
He does a lot of squats though.
Right?
That's what's interesting.
He's around like the greatest super
athletes in the known universe.
Actually.
It was pretty good.
Right for
today.
He was pretty good in those.
Random for today was.
I mean,
he's not always around the greatest
super athletes,
right?
No,
no.
Yeah,
yeah.
Um,
It looks pretty good.
It looks like he's in good shape.
Happy to take your shirt off with this
California stomach tattoo.
But the point being that guy is around,
he's around six foot five,
290 pounds super athletes who could jump
over his fucking head.
They literally could run through 100 of
him,
like they were paper walls,
just raw.
That's what he's around.
He's around the fucking super bowl,
the greatest physical specimens in the
known universe.
And he takes his shirt off like,
hey bitches,
I'm here to.
They had an event set up over the
weekend.
Uh,
some people could test their 40 speed up
against other NFL teams,
whatever.
They had this hilarious Hussein bolt did
it and it's in his shoes.
They said street shoes or whatever.
But she didn't have cleats on.
He tied the fastest ever.
NFL 40.
He's probably did with a full stomach.
It probably just a track a couple of
beers.
Fuck it.
I'll show these bitches what's up?
Yeah.
It's just,
it was weird like watching on tv,
it's due to shirt off,
like,
oh,
this is a different thing now.
Now this is like a sexy concert for.
It was like a football and that's what I
think he's getting shit for it because
he didn't need to take a shirt off.
Right.
You know,
he,
he had his shirt on and then like after
the second songs,
like,
you know what,
let's get sexy in the super bowl.
No,
no,
but I mean,
why else would you take this shirt?
At least make it Hashtag.
Hashtag sexy in the superbowl.
Gets sexy up in this bitch.
Well,
he's a sexy man.
Can't,
don't be hating.
Beautiful Man.
Yeah,
I mean,
but.
But that's the whole thing that your
audience is a bunch of guys jacket on
with Jack and on.
Well,
it was cold out at first,
but then he started to warm up a sweat.
Never trust white men with Nicholas's.
That's my message for the one now he's
got the little necklaces and the
bracelets for the falcons land on.
Wait a minute.
Those are spiritual Nicholas's.
If you have wooden beads for whatever
reason that makes you spiritual hemp or
gold.
I can't even tell you allowed to wear
necklaces because like people go,
oh,
you like really indoor ganache stuff
really into macro,
but that's gold is gold.
Yeah.
That's the other one was just a weird
lighting.
I can't wear necklaces,
man.
It bugs me.
Did you ever wear necklaces?
Necklaces?
Sure.
Yeah.
It's never been a staple,
but it's a,
it's a,
it's a weird thing if,
first of all,
if it's,
if it's big enough,
it's like this target,
right?
If you have like a bill gold necklace,
people want to steal it.
Right?
There's a lot of Nicholas snatchers out
there.
Brian,
I don't know if you know that.
Yeah.
But then the other thing is,
uh,
like what are you doing?
We're doing with that big old shiny
thing around your neck.
Are you doing.
What?
Are you a chick?
Remember it in the nineties,
chokers were thing and I used to wear a
choker.
How gross is that?
Like dog choker,
just a really tight necklace.
Yeah,
hemp necklaces.
Oh yeah.
Those were the little bead.
The bead at the bottom.
The beads.
Critical.
Kind of have the bead.
Yeah,
multicolored bead.
Think over.
You're cool.
Yeah.
Like,
it's weird,
like,
like some guys will wear like little
anklets with beads and they tie them off
and they'll walk around barefoot and
you're like,
okay,
what's kind of like that?
Look that you're not shop.
Look where you have like the really
tight,
like your pants go up so you can see
your socks,
you know,
you show a little leg.
You know why they do that or sneakers.
Those guys show off the sneakers.
False.
That's what she told me to do that
Jamie.
That's what my parents have that
actually for it.
That's how the uh,
that's funny.
That's how the pants are made.
You don't buy those pants,
man,
that you're not buying pants.
Where do you buy your parents?
Lady store.
Do you buy?
Do you buy it at coach?
Do you buy those pants?
Icu Doc on?
Gosh,
that's hilarious.
Do you don't do that too?
You know?
How dare you,
how dare you have a pair of a very
comfortable underarmor running shoes on?
How are those trouble?
That was in your shoes the other day.
Um,
they're a little too tight for me.
Okay.
They bind my feet a tad bit.
When I got to the store,
I had to swap them out for A.
I had a pair of converse all stars,
which you might go to.
You Got Yeezys right?
Jamie gave me a pair of yeezys about a
year ago and he just to talk to them.
You just keeping them on ice dead.
Socked him.
Is that always called that stock dead
stock.
Dead stock.
Oh.
Do you know a dead naming is?
Do you know what dead naming is of?
No,
no,
it's a new thing that's illegal on
twitter.
It just something I wish I knew I didn't
know until after the podcast,
but dead naming is a.
it's banned.
So say if you decided tomorrow to become
a woman and you're like,
I'm not no longer Bryan.
I'm Bryan INA Brianna.
That's what have you thought the
servers.
So I'd be like,
okay,
Brianna,
but you're still a man.
And then boom,
that's deadnaming you can't call someone
something other than their preferred
gender.
So like if that identify as a woman,
but their biologically male,
you're not allowed to say their
biologically male,
uh,
you're not allowed to call them a man
because that's deadnaming.
You not allowed to call them.
Like you couldn't call Caitlyn Jenner.
Bruce.
If you called her bruce,
you'd be dead naming her.
But that's just like,
that's not illegal or I mean like,
oh,
it's winter rule.
If it is a new poll,
please pull that up.
I did not know this.
It.
It's been around for awhile,
but I'm checking the twitter.
That's kind of weird.
Dead Name.
He has been banned for a while or don't
know.
The term term has been around.
I just found out about the term maybe a
couple weeks ago.
I had heard the term for the first time
somebody wrote dead naming and I was
like,
what?
What is that?
And then I had to look it up.
I saw the new rules.
We have to deal with that fucking
article.
There's an article that I was reading.
Go ahead.
I'm looking right at their terms of
service.
It's directly word for word in there.
Okay.
Where's this?
Dead naming of transgender individuals
repeated or nonconsensual slurs or
epithets?
Racist and sexist tropes or other
content that degrade someone.
Okay.
Well hold on a second.
Like what does degrade someone?
So if you.
If you contact me and say,
hey bro,
you're fucking short.
You're not funny.
That's degrading,
like is that not allowed?
That's crazy.
You have to.
You have to have that be allowed.
We are targeting individuals with
repeated slurs,
tropes or other content that it tends to
dehumanize,
degrade,
or reinforce negative or harmful
stereotypes about a protected category.
See,
that's where it comes from.
Like white people are not protected.
This includes targeted mis-gendering or
deadnaming of transgender transgender
individuals.
Oh,
I love how they just went with the giant
corporation and they just went with some
new word that's only been around for
like a month.
How long has deadnaming been around for
the urban dictionary?
Had It in there from 2014.
He never even heard that,
but they're on the ball.
Tell you that,
but you to stay ahead.
Twitter still allows goat season and all
the porn you want.
It was interesting to me.
Yeah.
Well,
porns consensual.
I love that.
That's hilarious.
That's all.
I love the.
I love the chaos of it all.
I love the fact that
trying to sort everything out.
I just think it's.
The whole thing is crazy.
It's so bizarre that
they're trying to,
in that sense with that like that's so
vague to dehumanize or degrade what
every joke about someone,
every joke about trump,
every single joke about trump that every
single comedian and slash or commentator
in or person makes is in some way
degrading.
When you talk about how fucking stupid.
It's like Rob Reiner had a joke about
him,
called him a piece of shit or call them
a piece of crap yesterday and said he
couldn't believe how fucking dumb he is.
Trump talking about hillary though.
He's doing it to him.
Percent.
One hundred percent.
So that's so vague.
That's so vague
and dead naming is not a real word.
So like how are they using fake words in
this?
They're trying to say it is now.
It is a real real word.
Yeah man.
I don't know if your name used to be
bruce and you change it to Caitlin.
I can't say that.
That seems bananas.
So like if you're fucking with somebody,
say somebody became a woman and it's
still an asshole.
Like you can't call him Mike,
you know.
Hey Mike,
look,
I'm sure you're bitter about this whole
changing your sex thing.
You can't bring that up.
But uh,
you're still an annoying guy.
You just don't have your deck anymore by
like if someone says that they can't say
that,
why can't they say that they should.
That's to me stupid.
Why?
Well,
I'm not saying that that's hurtful,
I guess to transgender people and that's
can be considered hate speech or hate
whatever but own.
But only when it comes to like gender,
right?
Like if you could tell someone,
hey,
you're short and fat and stupid and they
don't.
No one cares.
True.
Right?
You could say you,
uh,
you're ugly as fuck your noses.
Disgusting.
What happens there?
Is that the same?
What is it the same thing?
It might be if you do it repeatedly,
right?
If,
once you just throw one out there,
probably.
Okay.
Probably one time you could shit on
someone's looks.
But it's like what?
Like deciding what you can and shit on
someone for like what I'm saying is if
someone's an asshole and they're like,
here's a perfect one.
That woman who used to be a man,
she's transgender woman who was in a
store screaming at this kid behind the
counter that it's ma'am,
it's man,
this is a perfect example of that guy
was terrified.
She's fucking huge and she used to be a
guy and clearly still looks like a guy
and she's saying it's fucking ma'am.
Like you mentioned,
knocked some shit over.
She got violent.
Yeah.
In that situation you're telling me that
it's not cool to say,
how about you settle the fuck down
because you look like a guy.
You're acting like a violent guy and you
used to be a guy.
Pardon me if I think you're still a
fucking guy
that's deadnaming.
But that's a good thing to say in that
particular instance.
So without nuance,
right?
Without context,
it's saying you can't say anything to
degrade someone.
Well clearly that would degrade that
guy,
but if that guy was saying,
fuck that kid,
he did it on purpose.
On twitter you're saying someone can't
respond,
hey man,
I'm sure you're really upset that you
got your Dick or moved and these still
look your guy,
but fuck you.
Like why can't someone say that?
Because that's people communicating how
they feel about you being a dick.
Like if you start out being a dick and
then they communicate about you being a
dick by being a dick as well.
Are we banning?
This is the product is covering their
butts and there's probably not like of
like Jamie said,
it's dangerous in a lot of ways.
It's dangerous to control people's
thoughts and behavior because who are
you to say and when does it end?
You know?
It just keeps going and going and going
and going.
It gets.
It gets very slippery when you have one
group that thinks it's right and they're
trying to control another group that
thinks they're right.
Man,
that is a.
it's.
It seems so simple when you just talk
about deadnaming transgender people or
not degrading people based on their or
their ethnicity or their this or that,
but what you're doing is you're trying
to dictate how humans communicate with
each other and people don't like it when
you tell them what to do.
The problem with telling people what to
do is they want to do the exact opposite
is one of the first things you realize
when you have kids like,
oh,
they don't want to listen to me.
Like I got to figure out a way to sneak
information into them.
You know,
or you gotta you gotta figure out a way
to not be too bossy.
People don't want someone telling them
what to do.
This is what I missed when I was
editing,
headed into that conversation.
I missed how other people looked at that
guy and what he stands for.
I don't think it's correct.
I think it's way more complicated.
I think it's an insane business to run
it.
I don't think he really knew why Alex
Jones was band or anybody else has been.
I don't think he really knew.
I think he's dealing with a giant
corporation and he's a young guy
anywhere.
Sandals titling company here.
Wait,
wait.
What kind of Sandoz is a weird ones.
Like the Nice Guy.
Let's just choose.
He runs a couple of different companies.
He's not.
He's not sitting at twitter office.
That's another thing that Alex Jones
brought up today that he sponsors the
podcast through the cash app,
which is also.
He also runs 100 percent true,
but I would have,
and I think we talked about it on the
podcast.
We even talked about the cash app being
a sponsor and about how it's helped.
Justin wren is fight for the forgotten
charity.
So Alex Jones erroneously said that I
didn't mention it,
so we did mention it.
It's worth mentioning and Alex Jones is
a
having to like respond to people that
want to know if I've seen what Alex
Jones has said about me lately is one of
the weird things that I have dealt with
because first of all I've always had
good dealings with Alex in person,
person to person,
but he's obviously in a world of shit
right now.
There's a lot going on with him with the
sandy hook stuff and he wasn't entirely
honest with me about what he had said
about Sandy Hook.
Maybe he didn't remember.
Maybe a.
He was trying to phrase it in a way
other than the way I interpreted it when
I saw the videos,
but there is a media matters video that
shows all the time where he said that
Sandy Hook was fake.
This is a very complicated.
To me,
this is one of the reasons why I
struggled with bringing him back on the
podcast.
That's very complicated.
It's that is.
Even though
I've known the guy since 1998 and if I'm
around him,
I'd say that's my friend Alex Jones.
He's a friend.
He's awfully.
He obviously did something fucked up and
the parents that had to deal with what
he did.
There's parents that had to deal with
people calling them a crisis actor.
They had to deal with people harassing
them at the courthouse and harassing
them if they met them in public because
they were saying that they were lying
about their kids being killed.
So not only are their kids being killed,
but they have to deal with someone
harassing them and saying,
you're a liar and you're enactor.
It's insanity and I wouldn't.
I would think about it differently.
I definitely think about differently if
I wasn't friends with Alex,
but I would also think about it
differently if he hadn't made shit up
about me.
He said that I was told to stop talking
about conspiracies are they threatened
my family that's 100 percent horseshit
and he has my phone number he could have
called me.
I called him after I heard about it.
He told me that someone told him that.
I told.
I talked to the person who told him that
I'm like,
this is fucking bananas.
Like you out of your mind,
call me.
This is so stupid.
You think I'm not talking about
whatever.
Fill in the blank.
Whatever.
Ridiculous conspiracy,
the rothschilds,
the Rockefeller's,
whatever it is.
I'm not talking about that because the
government threatened my family.
That is fucking wrong.
It's ridiculous.
And now you've put it out there.
So Alex Jones went on afterwards and he
apologized and corrected it.
Then recently,
because I haven't had him on the
podcast,
he decided to start saying that I worked
for the CIA and that,
um,
uh,
George Soros talking points,
which I don't even know what these
fucking talking points,
our talking points about him and
specific not talking to anybody.
No one's giving me talking points,
not George Soros,
Eddie Bravo has been saying he wasn't
good.
He got good information.
Even say that.
So stop.
Joey Diaz did fuck with it for awhile
though.
But,
but the point being,
the point being Alex is you're out
there.
I still like you as a person.
If I saw you,
I'd still give you a hug,
but you're making shit up.
And this is,
this is not helping anybody wants to
defend you.
It's not helping me as a person.
Talk about the good qualities in you and
you know,
the,
these things that you're saying are made
up.
You're making up the fact that I'm in
the CIA.
You're making up for the fact that the
Hollywood insiders have given me
information and tell me what to say.
That's not true.
You know,
it's not true.
You know me.
I don't have time to be a CIA insider.
I can't take on another job and between
doing standup and podcasts and UFC
commentator,
running a family,
I can't do it.
I wouldn't do it.
I'm not interested.
I'd rather stop doing everything than
work for any government organization.
No one's ever approached me.
No one's ever approached anybody I've
ever heard of.
I don't even know if that really
happens.
I don't know if that's a real thing.
The thing is they always say is that the
CIA would talk to the people in
Hollywood and tell them what to say in
terms of propaganda and maybe.
I don't know.
I don't have any personal knowledge of
it.
I'm sure someone has decided that if
they're going to make a movie about like
zero dark 30,
that they have to get some sort of
approval and I'm sure that a lot of
movies that are very inspirational that
have to do with the military would be
great for recruitment.
So I'm sure there's some involvement.
I'm sure there's also some patriots that
work in show business that want to put
out these movies about the government
and about the military in a very
positive way.
That's probably the case in some
instances too,
but not everything's a fucking
conspiracy and this is why it's stupid.
It's stupid is some things are fucking
conspiracy.
And Alex Jones has talked about some
things that were real conspiracies,
that nine slash 11 documentary,
the road to tyranny details the world
trade organization protests where they
sent in these agent provocateur tours
that which are essentially soldiers.
They send in soldiers and military
people dressed up in all black and cover
their face and they smashed windows and
tip over things and they take a peaceful
protest and they turn it violent.
So then the police can move in and shut
down the protest.
And then not only did they do that,
but they made a no protest zone.
And the United States of America,
uh,
no protest zone.
Was it the United States of America?
Wasn't Vancouver,
was.
It was Seattle,
I think Seattle coover.
No,
I think at Seattle World Trade
Organization protests template with the
boots and they all have that shit,
but Alex detailed this in detail and it
was real when he makes things up.
Like there was one recently,
the David Pakman show had on about Alex
talking about people eating babies
pituitary glands and scattered vandalism
of downtown Seattle.
Yeah,
seattle.
So the enforce a no protest zone.
That was in 2009 in 1999 rather.
Was It [inaudible] 99.
December first 1999.
The October 27.
Two thousand nine was the article.
Yeah,
Alex did that.
That was real.
That was legit and it was very
informative because I didn't know that
that is how the government operates
sometimes.
Did you contact him the second time and
go,
what the fuck are often.
I send them a text message,
so this is why I won't talk to you.
You say crazy stupid shit like this,
but I don't hate the guy.
He's,
you know,
he'll scream and yell and call me a
demon.
He's not a good place.
You're not in a good place when you're
defending against that.
And what all these other conspiracies,
like it's all fun and games until you're
talking about people's kids getting
murdered and then all of a sudden people
are like,
fuck you.
And that's basically what happen with
him.
If he was just ranting about government
conspiracies or you know,
who shot this guy or who's stealing
money from here.
Some of what he talks about is
beneficial.
But Alex is not.
I don't think he's in a good place.
I don't think he's in a good place
mentally.
And I don't.
I don't think he's in a good place in
terms of his situation with the law.
Don't hate you.
Alex Jones.
If you listen to this,
if I saw you,
I'd still give you a hug.
I'll still even do your fucking show
when I come to Austin.
I don't care.
You can,
we can come and hang out,
but just stop making shit up.
It's silly.
And you know,
I'm sorry if there's bad stuff between
us.
A more.
Sorry of what you said about those kids.
I'm sorry about everything.
It's,
it's unfortunate.
It's all terrible now.
Something like that.
What's the road to redemption for
someone like that because some.
This is the thing about people is,
and I think this is also what's going on
with Alex.
people need a road to redemption.
Like if if someone fucks up horribly and
does something terrible,
should that be the end of them?
This idea that we don't need them
anymore,
no matter who it is.
I mean what?
What does a person have to do to grow
and learn and for people just accept
them again and lead them on to all
platforms again.
What,
what?
What does a person have to do?
It's a real good question.
I think it's
per person though.
Like somebody like Alex just seems like
he's getting worse and worse.
Like this seems like what he did teach
us.
You mad at me because I haven't had them
on that.
He,
I'm sure to you he asked you or if he
was in town?
No,
no.
Do you not listening?
I said I didn't want to have them on
one.
I was trying to figure out whether I
would have him on,
but when I watched the media matters
video,
it was very clear to me he wasn't being
on.
I asked him if he had said that it was
fake and he said he questioned whether
or not it was real,
but then eventually he acknowledged that
it was real,
which he has done,
but there was many times where he said
it was fake.
Not One,
many times.
It's absolutely fake.
It was 100 percent fake.
There's video of it.
I didn't see the video before.
We did our nine slash 11 podcast.
I've seen it now and I still thought
about having them on.
I still thought about talking to them
about it and talking to them about all
this shit and what it's like.
I think it's.
He plays a character.
Honestly.
I don't think so.
I mean with the reptiles guys and people
and the things that he says,
none of it.
Half of it's just like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I think he.
He definitely goes,
goes crazy with some things,
but I don't think he's doing well,
but he was talking about eating babies.
Pituitary glands were found fondant.
David Pakman video.
David Pakman,
who's a progressive,
a commentator online.
He,
he was going,
look,
something's wrong with him.
Like he's playing this video,
like what he's talking about them
breaking into
what is happening in the Alex Jones.
Yeah.
See if you can find the part on the
video where Alex is talking.
It's early on.
It sounds like schizophrenia.
It sounds like any episode of live pd or
cops and people are talking like,
I saw aliens upstairs in my house,
you know,
like the other guy,
Owen Benjamin,
look at him,
see,
play this place real quick.
It's all in plain view of these people.
They're just putting it in our face.
They want a system where we can't do
anything to stop them.
That's like Bill Maher,
the name of his production company as a
kid.
Love,
which is enabled slogan.
Basically.
They make jokes about having sex with
kids all the time and she says it's okay
to have sex with.
You know,
kids don't have section 35 year olds
when they're 12,
just incredibly evil,
pathetic stuff of these solas demons
like Bill Maher.
But Josh was saying he had a theory,
the only one walnut saw says USA.
It's the pituitary gland because they
confirm that Jimmy Chevelle and others
would a torsional kids to death,
but they couldn't get regular ones to
kill.
Her favorite thing was to grab a kid,
run over with the car so they could say,
oh,
there's a police report.
They are run our.
But they would hurry to the morgue and
they work with different,
different government controlled morgues
and eat the pituitary gland as quickly
as possible,
uh,
and,
and get high off of it.
So yes.
Yeah.
That's this.
First of all,
Bill Maher's done a fucking pedophile.
This,
this is crazy.
This is like a weird rambling and this
is not alex that I knew from 1998.
So it's not,
it's not the same guy.
This is a guy who's not doing well.
So my apology,
um,
as a human being to Alex Jones,
if uh,
you were hurt that I didn't have you
back on the show if you were hurt that I
occasionally poke fun at you.
I have to.
You're hilarious unfortunately.
But,
uh,
I don't hate you.
Don't wish you wish you badly.
And uh,
back in the day I enjoyed a lot of your
stuff.
People lose their way,
you know,
so
I think that,
um,
it's a real bad feeling being stuck on
the outside too when they all band
together and kick you out and everybody
kicks you out.
Everybody,
twitter and facebook and everybody and
Youtube and twitter was the last one.
But uh,
that was Jack Dorsey didn't even know
why Alex Jones got kicked off twitter
and people like,
well,
let them back in.
Then like,
yeah,
but somebody knows somebody.
Like,
I don't think Jack Dorsey is really the
guy who's looking at each individual
person that gets banned.
I just have a feeling that that stuff is
compartmentalized.
Right?
I told you 100 percent,
7 million monthly active users.
Right?
But how many people are.
I'm responsible for banning people and
real high profile people though.
I'm sure there's a whole,
like maybe 12 people.
They have to have a meeting.
Then they,
you know,
maybe they talked to Jack,
maybe they don't.
Maybe they,
they position who.
Yeah,
right.
He,
maybe he doesn't.
We don't know.
I'll ask that for sure.
But maybe he didn't know when people got
banned until he liked maybe got
accompany memo.
Maybe he wasn't involved in the course.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe he's the one that called them up
and said,
get rid of this motherfucker that's
possible too.
Like,
here's another one,
right?
Here's one that people had an issue
with.
And one thing you could say,
okay.
I'm like,
uh,
when Kathy Griffin held up the,
the,
the trump head,
remember that?
Um,
did she do that on her own twitter
account?
Uh,
yeah,
she,
well,
a photo of it.
When she posted,
she posted on instagram or twitter.
I think it was on both.
I'm not 100 percent sure.
Right.
So that it's A.
is it allowed?
It's allowed because it's newsworthy
because it's a celebrity and the
celebrity is threatening a public figure
who is also the most powerful person in
the world.
So it's.
Okay.
Did that,
why that is.
I think she posted it because it was an
art piece that was kind of
controversial.
Oh No,
no.
I know that.
And that's what I'm saying.
Why are saying why is it okay?
Why is she still allowed to be on the
platform?
And Alex Jones case kicked off.
That's a,
it's an interesting question,
right?
Like,
what do you need to do to get kicked
off?
Because that's not the only thing that
Kathy's done.
Um,
recently she was one of the people that
was calling for the name for that young
boy who was,
um,
with that native American in front of
his face beating the drum.
She's crazy,
irresponsible,
you know,
I'm sure she feels bad about it now in
retrospect,
especially if she's watched the video,
but you got carried away and she
thought,
what we all thought when you saw the
picture that smirking can't have a kid
that got in the face,
this beautiful indigenous man is singing
his,
his rain dance cry or whatever the fuck
he's doing.
Yeah.
That's not what it was though.
We found out afterwards it was much more
complicated.
What is their song?
What were they saying?
Sounded cool.
They should make a record.
Yeah.
Do you like that shit?
That shit's cool to listen to.
When you work out,
if you could get like some,
some legit native American chance like
that puts you into a trance.
Right?
If you don't know what they're saying
and you just go running and you listen
to that.
Took a little couple tokes.
Go for.
Go for a jog in the woods,
listening to native American chance on
your air ponds.
That was an interesting video though
because I mean I was a one 80 after just
hearing the second side of the story,
like 12 hours later people still were
calling for that guy's head.
Yeah.
And people.
I saw someone who said,
um,
what's his name?
Ron Perlman?
No,
who's the guy who was a hellboy?
Ron Ron Perlman was like,
motherfuckers telling me that I'm not
seeing what I'm seeing.
And she said something about some white
prick or white motherfucker.
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
People try so hard.
Like you,
you are seeing what you're seeing.
You're seeing what you're saying.
Well,
you're not seeing is a video that shows
how it occurred.
That's all it is,
you know?
So why is that?
Okay?
Right.
Why is that okay?
Why is it okay for some journalists to
say horrible things about white people?
Why is that okay?
It seems weird.
What if it encourages violence against a
innocent white person?
Just one should be responsible.
What if they say,
why did you do that?
Well,
I read Blah,
blah,
blah as a tweet.
And I was like,
you know what,
I am going to go out and punch a white
person.
Fuck that.
I just found some white old lady and I
beat her ass.
Like if someone decides that you're not
responsible for that or yeah,
probably not.
But you kind of feel
like you played a part in the way people
look at things,
especially people that are very easily
influenced,
you know?
It's just also,
it's gross.
He reads something really racist against
white people.
You're like,
that's gross.
Like you think all,
all people are like that.
A whole group of people that don't have
as much melanin.
They're all shit.
That's ridiculous.
You're ridiculous person.
I don't care if you're brown or black or
yellow,
you're ridiculous.
That's silly because we have to decide.
It's got to decide like what the fuck
we're doing.
If we keep letting illogical behavior be
normal,
like breaking us off into fucking groups
like that and thinking that you know,
all men are great or all women are great
or all gays are great and never all
straight cisgendered men can go fuck
themselves.
All right,
that's,
that's silly talk.
I don't care who you are,
you're not allowed to do that,
but we let people do that.
If they're a part of a marginalized
class,
if someone's a part of a marginalized
then you get to shit on everybody.
In a weird way.
You get to like reinforce racism.
It's really.
It's so fucking counterproductive too
because if you do that then it just
makes people just get defensive on the
other side.
They don't even want to even think or
empathize with how you are.
What social media has really made.
Everything annoying has made me think
great too though.
Both do twitter is like we're saying
when someone says something dumb like
trump will say something dumb sometimes
and I'll just go there for the memes and
I'll just read his post and it'll get me
going in the morning.
I'll get like 15 minutes of [inaudible].
Probably missed the story yesterday.
Have you heard any of the 21 savage
news?
Oh,
you got deported,
right?
Because everyone found out yesterday
that he's apparently from the UK and so
like the story.
There's two stories that as part of the
story,
but memes of him being from the UK and
the British rapper that's rosie from
Atlanta really took over to the fact
like Demi Lovato tweeted it and she got
shit on and she's deleted her twitter
now because of the response to that.
Did you know who this guy was before?
No,
but I'm 51 years old.
Yes,
man.
Number one,
like Oh shit.
write record.
And now like in the country.
Really?
But Jamie's on black twitter,
twitter.
But you're on black twitter.
Sure,
sure I'd be.
I.
Oh yeah.
My father.
A lot of them.
I don't know any of these.
Tech Nines and Sushi for fucked that.
Takeshi.
Six nine.
He's fucked.
Maybe.
What do you mean?
Maybe he's talking.
He's still fucked.
He's.
He's fun.
He's going to jail for a long time with
a tattoo of six,
nine on his face.
He's going to jail.
Who's going to have real problems?
That ain't good.
You read the list of charges.
There's murder involved.
Murder conspiracy of him supposedly
calling a hit on someone.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
Oh,
he's fucked.
Even if he cooperates,
if they put a hit on someone because he
said it,
Jesus he'll hear,
won't get like the death penalty,
but now he'll be like life in prison or
you know someone's fleshlight.
Yeah.
Heck yeah.
It's a real problem.
Soldier boys in jail too is.
I mean it is.
For what got arrested.
Did he beat up his girl and his girl
beat him up?
No,
no,
that was a little bit while he's son of
a bitch.
You just shamed soulja boy for no
reason.
With your shitty pot.
Adult memory,
right?
I know.
It was a little bow.
Wow.
No,
there was something else.
Hold on.
Yep.
Is Accused of kidnapping a woman happy.
I'm sorry.
So you got the stories conflated.
Kidnapping.
Because even worse,
he tied a girl to a,
a,
a chair using an extension cord and kept
her for six or seven hours in his
garage.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
he's going to jail forever.
Prom.
What did he do that.
But that's someone's daughter wouldn't
do that for a jealousy.
I think it said.
This is apparently according to
celebrity news outlet.
The woman whose name I will not say
apparently was backing out of a driveway
in her car,
hit soldiers la home when she hit the
curb or at his house when she hit the
curb.
From that point on,
his assistant reportedly became upset
and started fighting with her from
there.
Soldier allegedly stepped outside and
tried to break up the fight.
The woman says that he began punching
and kicking her when she was on the
ground and then tied her up for six
hours.
God,
Soulja boy.
Well,
at least Nintendo one wish that cooler
heads will prevail,
but that sounds like that sounds like a
fucking disaster.
Jesus Christ.
You never hear about the spin doctors
causing any problems.
Right guys?
She hit a curb.
This all started.
She heard it.
She hit a curb with his car or
something.
She's curb one of his wheels.
Wasn't enough information on there.
I don't know.
Yeah,
she probably curbed one of his wheels.
It was a nice car and she didn't know
what the fuck she was doing.
I can drive
what a Dick tied her up and beat her up,
allegedly,
allegedly.
Right,
right,
right.
You got to always say that.
Denied by this.
Did you see that video,
that old man putting the ice on the
ground and then pretending he fell.
Oh,
that's.
Yeah.
Allegedly brilliant.
Allegedly,
allegedly.
Allegedly.
There's no allegedly lead for that.
It's amazing.
It's amazing to watch because he didn't
know there was a security camera there.
Tried to collect.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that do that,
man.
I've seen videos of people doing that at
the mall.
They'll like throw a drink down and then
slide down on the drink.
We had a guy do it once at a movie
theater I worked at and we had it on
video also and we just showed them the
video and then he left and never heard
anything about it,
but he was bitching up a storm like he
was hurt was me.
This guy,
this guy's hilarious.
So he's walking.
He looks around chuck some ice on the
ground.
A little bit of a nightstand.
No big deal.
I'm gonna go over here and la Di da Di
da.
I left this fall.
Watch this.
He looks around and make sure no one's
looking.
Oh.
Even felt like a bitch.
It's like holding is the most ridiculous
look.
That silly,
silly,
silly man.
The thing about those guys is like
anybody that does that kind of shit,
I think the cops,
all they have to do is go,
sure what's your social security number?
And they look up all the shit that he's
also done.
Like you don't that even just a little
bit of a scam.
That's a guy who's been scam and it's
like in Russia and stuff or other
countries where everyone's doing the
insurance scams.
And so to the point where everybody has
to have dash cams on their car.
Now there's a lot of that just triggered
a story I heard over the weekend.
There was a not,
it's,
I think this is a story happening in
Houston where the cops broke into a
house where they had heard that there
was or they think they had a warrant.
A report was that neighbors had called
and black tar heroin sales or something
like that at this house.
So they broke in without knocking.
It was like a no knock warrant.
Uh,
the guys like 57 in the house,
here's someone break into his house,
gets a shotgun,
shoots one of the cops that killed him.
His wife is like,
what the fuck's going on?
She goes to try to grab the other cops
gun that had just fallen.
She gets shot,
two people are dead and they didn't find
any heroine.
Oh Geez.
There's like some weed in there or
something like that.
And some people are like,
they didn't have a history of doing much
from what I read.
That's why I thought of it because they
look back with these guys.
Do they have an arrest history or
anything?
And it wasn't anything that they had
found,
at least what I read about it.
Do you remember the one where there was
a mayor outside of Washington DC and he,
uh,
they were using his house as an address
and it was something with the mail
delivery guy was running weed.
And so the mail delivery guy would come
by and uh,
the package was addressed to him,
but he would just keep the package
because he knew that this was this guy's
house.
It was on his route and that way,
you know,
as the package came into mail would be
his to deliver,
but instead of delivering it he would
hold onto it.
So they break into the mayor's house?
No.
You know the whole shoot his fucking
dogs shoon his dog and he had like one
of my dog like Marshall.
So like a super duper sweet dog,
either yellow lab,
which is real similar.
I think it was a yellow,
might've been golden retriever.
Either way they fucking shot at least
one of his dogs.
How did they not know that was the
mayor's house you think that would be
like on a list day,
didn't Google shit or maybe they did.
Maybe they thought fucking the mayors.
A drug dealer.
Maybe they really thought that,
but that kind of shit is dark man.
We just go shoot a golden retriever.
Come on,
you're not a pussy and I know you're
going in there because you think that
this is a real drug running operation
because the cops just got bad
information.
Right?
But you're not a pussy.
You don't have to shoot a fucking
labrador stop.
You think that things going to bite you
will when it does shoot it then.
So I'm going to play you the fuck out of
here.
That's a weird power trip.
Shit thing.
Shoot all dogs know if.
Look,
if a guy's got a wolf and it's off the
chain,
it's running out you.
Yeah,
shoot it.
You break in into some guy's house and
then you shoot his fucking dog.
What if you're wrong?
Look,
you are a lot.
You cool with
shoot and someone's fucking dog in front
of their kids.
That's what happened to the mayor of
this town.
The fucking mayor.
I bet the guy was a mail carrier.
Just thought it was cute to use the
mayor's address.
Get all the weed delivered.
Maybe you didn't.
Maybe voted for his opponent.
He thought it was safer to do it that
way.
Oh,
did you get a tesla?
Are you just driving around?
Oh,
God was telling me how.
How do you like it?
I had to get one.
I told them,
you live in Moscow.
I would get one guy did my podcast.
I almost solid.
I'm a man of my word.
Uh,
it's a fucking spaceship.
It's the weirdest thing I've ever driven
in my life.
It doesn't even make sense.
It's not even.
Not even.
There's not a single car that I've ever
driven that's even close to his fast.
Nothing like,
my porsche is so slow.
I have a gt three Rs.
It has 518 horsepower.
Waste 3000 pounds.
It sounds like a dragon.
And that Tesla would leave it in the
dust.
I mean,
leave it in the dust like zero to 62
seconds quicker.
It's fucking insane and out of a no.
Ludicrous.
Yeah,
I did.
I put it in chill mode for a little
while,
but you could drive chill with ludicrous
mode.
Always available.
You don't have to keep switching back.
And little mode is just crazy,
like the fastest and it kills your
battery.
Well,
it kills your battery quicker,
but the thrust that you get is a roller
coaster ride.
It's insane.
I mean,
you can't believe how fast it is.
It doesn't even.
It literally doesn't make sense.
It doesn't seem right.
It seems like like it's punching its way
through a wormhole use an alien
technology.
Meanwhile I posted,
it seems like something Bob was our
snuck out of area 51.
I get all these messages from people.
has been debunked.
That's controlled opposition.
That's a fake story.
It's fake news bro.
They got you with the Bob Story.
Do you like all the tech in it?
That's the same one.
It's too much almost because it's this
giant screen.
Like I had a dim it where the fuck down
because I was looking at it like you're
so pretty,
so pretty.
It's so pretty.
Dream car.
It's very comfortable.
How long?
Super comfortable.
Now do you have a supercharged station
at your house yet or do you thing on the
wall?
At my house that I can plug it into a
supercharger.
It takes like eight hours.
Eight hours or more.
And how many miles,
but I'm going to get one of those.
I'm going to get one of those fast
charger in the house because allegedly,
and I mean allegedly 311 miles.
Do you have the fuel?
But here's the problem.
I drive like a mall wrong,
so it's not going that far.
Did you get,
is there a few option for that model and
like are you cool?
I think there's a fuel add on that gives
you an extra like,
oh,
that's an option.
Like I thought you meant a fuel
gasoline.
Yeah,
I know.
What are you talking to?
Some models will not tesla.
Okay,
good.
Just making shit up bro.
Some,
some.
Uh,
I think it was car.
It is
extra for like one gallon of gas.
So like
if you ever lose your battery.
I have heard of that.
Yeah.
What was that?
I thought Tesla had that.
No,
no,
no.
There was like a Prius.
Prius is our mixed.
They're hybrids.
Prius's use gasoline,
but a very stingy amount of gasoline.
They run partially on electric motors.
So Do,
uh,
the Acura NSX.
The ACURA NSX has two electric motors,
but I think you don't ever charge it.
I think the electric motors are powered
by the gasoline engine and electricity
in the car,
if I remember right.
That's supposed to be the motherfucker
like the Acura Nsx is supposed to be the
car that people are underlooked under
looking for whatever reason,
it just doesn't get the love that it
deserves.
And apparently the 2019 models even more
insane.
I can't wait to the day where like your
garage floor is like a wireless charging
mat.
You just pull right up into the mat or
they would never would be because it's
rubber.
Well there I'm sure they're fine because
like there's a,
there's,
there's like if you,
if you take your phone and put it on a
wireless charger,
there's like a little room that if you
don't have to touch it,
like maybe that's the whole reason why
you're safe from getting hit by
lightning bro.
Yeah,
I like that.
The rubber protects you from
electricity.
Parco a little thing comes down to the
ground.
Like that thing falls out while you're
driving your car over.
Or did they?
If the streets like if somehow like if
you were riding on the highway and if
you want to fuel up that you can like
fuel up using the road.
Like pay like a fee or something.
Ideally it would be great if solar
panels had gotten so powerful.
They can charge it just with the sun,
especially because southern California
is always fucking sunny except for
today,
but it's a matter of time.
The cars of the future.
That's what it is.
It really is.
Look,
I'm a giant fan of American muscle cars
there.
My all time favorite cars in terms of
like to drive to hear the rumble of the
engine and that I love them.
I love them.
Maybe I'm some crazy old dude from the
fucking eighties that still loves 19
sixties muscle cars.
Maybe.
I don't care.
I love him,
but that fucking cars,
that future,
that Tesla is the future.
Like when you drive it,
you realize,
Oh,
other cars are stupid.
Is that.
That's that new room.
New Crazy rocket today.
Shooting rockets out in his backyard.
Is that his house?
Is there anything that you don't like on
the day or something that kind of bugs
you that you wish was like,
oh,
I don't have.
There's no door handles.
No,
no,
no.
Nothing.
You just got to figure it out.
It just takes a little while to figure
out what all different buttons do and
how to,
how to get things to happen,
but it's really well thought out.
It's a look.
He's a legit genius,
you know,
and what he's doing is unprecedented and
this is gonna sound like I'm kissing his
ass because I liked him because he did
the podcast and then I became friends
with them.
Know he's important.
The guys got ideas that are of a
magnitude that dummies,
like you and me are never going to come
up with any of those ideas ever.
If we lived a thousand lives,
we would never figure out space x.
it's just not in our wheelhouse.
We would never make a fucking electric
car.
We never make one of those things.
Never make a.
That Tesla roadster that's going to come
out.
That goes zero to 60 in one point nine
seconds and looks like like a spaceship,
like a,
like a race car spaceship from the
future.
We're not doing that dude.
We need people like that.
Those guys are super important.
This guy is a.
he's like a a culture changer,
like a legit culture changer.
He got him to smoke weed.
Jesus they want to do is the ad blocker
bus to want.
I'm looking forward to new Toyota supra.
That's the new one.
Looks Dope.
So this is the a space x rocket.
So what does it say at the top?
It says,
built a stainless steel rocket ship in
Texas that looks like liquid silver and
might launch in February.
Didn't what year?
What Day is this article?
January 11th.
A couple weeks ago.
Okay.
It fell over and I know that they've
been doing stuff more with it,
but I just how cool it looks it looks
like.
But I mean it did now.
It fell on the ground while I was
standing there.
Yeah.
It got blown over the wind.
It looks like a drawing for a rocket
from the 19 hundreds.
I don't know if he did it on purpose,
but it looks just like.
It looks like a fucking movie.
Like buck Rogers Rogers rocket.
You're right.
It looks dope though.
Roger's do.
Driving that car really feels like like
the future.
And did you get the best model or is
that.
Of course he did.
But yeah,
I got the model s p 100 ds.
What it's called.
I just paid off my car and might just
sell it and get one of those.
So have a place to park it that has a
little charge port.
Yeah,
I mean I have it in a power outlet.
I think you'd probably convert it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's a couple of superchargers in
Burbank.
Yeah,
there's one across the street,
but it's always taken.
I don't know what the.
You know,
what's weird man passing by gas stations
and going,
I'm never going to use it with this.
I've never pull it in there unless I
want a soda.
Look at that thing.
That's zero to 60 in one point nine
seconds.
And I'm telling you,
man,
that's not an unrealistic number.
Six hundred 20 miles.
Yes.
Wait,
when does this come out?
A couple of years.
It's going to be awhile.
Uh,
I'm going to get at 100 percent by your
old one.
This is such a dope car,
man.
It doesn't even make sense.
Why has it not have a side mirror?
It's got no side mirrors as cameras.
Fuck the rendering of it.
Probably shut your mouth.
God Damn side mirror you.
Sons of bitches.
I,
I love my camera cameras on my car.
I don't even use my side mirrors.
It's so much better having that look at
that thing.
How much is that?
600.
Twenty miles.
I Dunno.
Probably stupid.
Expensive.
Look how pretty it is.
It's too pretty to be cheap.
Got fucking sick.
That thing looks.
Look at it.
I mean it's like the ultimate sports car
like that looks like a.
That easily could be a new nine slash
11.
Like from that angle particularly.
And then the roof comes off.
Cameras Look at those game receipts
right there.
Well not only that,
but.
Well that's what racing seats.
That's why they were racing seats first
and then became gamers.
But the steering wheel's wonky steering
wheels.
Like a [inaudible],
like a formula one car.
See it?
Oh,
it's like square.
Yeah.
It's like you grab it by the handles.
Maybe they want to make sure that you
don't do this kind of shit like you.
This is so fast.
You probably need to hold onto it in a
different way.
Dude,
I'm telling you that the car that I.
That I got beautiful.
I've never experienced anything like
that before.
You don't think it's real.
You don't think a car can do that?
Doesn't make any sense.
Why do you want her $45,000?
Damn.
Chop back chat.
Oh my gosh,
that's five plus the 5,000.
Fifty thousand to 50.
Yeah.
It's probably gonna sell out in five
seconds to pay it.
Every.
Every dickhead in Hollywood will have
one.
Look at me.
I'm environmentally conscious,
but still success look like I'm an open
shirt to do.
Do,
do,
do.
I went into a volt the other day as an
uber.
Now is amazed by that.
Pretty sweet.
I think that's a hybrid right now.
It's all electric.
Yeah.
I mean it had like five different
cameras and it was pretty sweet.
Did he ask him how long the range is a
he?
Yeah.
It wasn't as good as I think of.
It's like 2:30,
I think he said that's not bad though.
If you drive it around Hollywood,
you could probably get a whole night and
you know if you're ubering.
Audi just announced theirs yesterday
with a super bowl commercial.
Oh,
it looks nasty.
I've seen it.
It looks for honesty.
Yeah,
it looks nasty.
Like Jesse Jackson.
Nastier bad nasties.
Ms Dot Jackson and it looks like A.
I think it's a different one.
I'm thinking of the r eight they took
kit that I get the look,
that stupid girl.
It looks like a regular Audi's what it
looks like,
but a Audi.
Google a audi electric sportscar.
There's one that doesn't look bad.
It looks like a stock standard suv.
That looks pretty good.
Second Mile on that thing.
What's the mileage?
The range.
The range is everything on these
fucking.
Exactly.
Because if it's anything below like 300
miles,
100 back up comparing it,
it's comparing the amount of time you
charge it and what it takes to charge to
get certain things.
Oh,
the model.
The final model.
Excellent.
He does 144 miles and 160 miles.
That ain't good.
It's on that trip.
On that kind of charger or something
like that.
Dude,
don't estimate.
That ain't good after 30 minutes.
It's only after 30 minutes.
Oh,
how much you get in 30 minutes?
Well that's not.
That's pretty good info.
So you can get 160 miles where the
charge in 30 minutes.
That's not bad.
Faster.
That's a long time though.
If you've got to go somewhere.
If you're in a rush,
you can't just pull it and get gas,
but you don't want the kind of power
that would it take.
I mean,
you imagine how many dip shit.
That's it.
That's the.
That's the Audi.
Look at that thing Brian.
Oh yeah.
I like that.
I like that better.
No,
that's,
that's the one.
So it's basically an Audi r eight,
a next generation Audi r eight.
Go to the one.
That's what it looks like.
That's a nasty looking car.
So dope electric
e-tron that says that says 2016 when
they announced it back at the car shows
and whatnot.
It's just probably what they're calling.
See Google,
see if it actually is a real thing or is
it still just a concept because a,
they always like,
there's a lot of those cars.
They'll disappoint shit out of you.
Two hundred $79.
Million Miles.
Oh,
it's.
So it's a real thing.
When is it available?
Wonder when that's going on.
Said Twenty,
22 right there.
20,
22.
Yeah.
So that's probably the same time the
rose just coming out.
But look how they get your Dick hard
years in advance.
She could have ordered it in 2015.
So rude though.
Oh Man.
So rude to get your dick hard so far in
advance.
Yeah.
You know,
like if you're like,
yeah,
I'm going to be fucking super
environmental but I'm going to show,
but it would still be stunting.
Wow.
Do you see the new Volkswagen Dune
buggy?
That looks pretty fun.
No.
What is that?
It's a cell.
A Dune buggy.
It was just announced.
Uh,
I'm not sure if when it's for sale or if
it's for sale,
but it looks pretty fun.
It's a,
it looks like a classic Dune Buggy,
but they vote Volkswagen date and it has
no roof,
but it was like a little fun car and on
the third see a picture of that and um,
yeah.
All right.
It's a new one.
Yeah.
So it looks kind of cool.
Right?
Whoa.
You could drive that on the road.
Yeah.
So it's a road car,
but is it still a Dune buggy?
Twenty to 25 again,
you sons of bitches.
That looks fun.
Well,
they were supposed to announce the new
Bronco.
Everybody thought it was going to happen
at the Detroit auto show,
but it came and went,
came and went with no bronco.
That makes no sense that because it's
actually on their website,
like they were going to announce it soon
as for sale.
I thought,
I don't think they said that they were
gonna they probably don't have it down.
You know,
sometimes when they're working on these
experimental vehicles they uh,
they'll develop something but then they
don't like certain aspects of it or then
maybe they are aware of a competitors
work that might come out with more
horsepower.
So they have to,
like for instance,
like the,
um,
the gt $500 from Ford,
uh,
it was on its way out there.
There we're going to put it out the new
one,
but they were saying that it has over
700 horsepower.
That's a.
They never say that.
They always give you the exact specific
number.
They always say 750 horsepower is coming
in 20,
20 there website.
Okay.
But did,
they didn't show it at the.
Not going to make a special day for
that.
That might be interested in going to be
nasty.
Look and see what it looks like.
It looks cool as fuck,
right?
That's right.
It's the Ford website doesn't have
pictures of it because they haven't
released it yet.
Um,
but uh,
what was I just saying?
What was I just saying?
I said we're talking about what before
the Bronco,
the Volkswagen Beetle bug.
Oh,
you were saying the Bronco.
I don't remember.
Jamie fucked me about how that's getting
pushed back because you know,
somebody who might like,
this car's faster.
Yeah,
that's right.
The shelby gt 500.
They said it's only so it's over 700
horsepower.
The reason why they said that is because
dodge came out with the demon and then
they came out with some other version of
the hellcat.
It's also an 800 horsepower,
so if you come out with only 700
horsepower,
it's hard because is ridiculous as that
sounds.
Some people gonna think you,
but it's not the Zr one that's good.
Seven 50 or it's not that this or that.
So they.
They haven't said exactly what the
horsepower rating is because they're
still trying to juice it up.
That might be the case of the Bronco
too.
They might be trying to fix things and
choose things,
but look how good that looks.
Red with the black stripes.
Good Lord.
Love black seat.
That cars are reckless person's car.
That's the difference between that and
like a tesla.
What's exciting about that car?
The way it looks,
that is a ridiculous person's car.
I can drive around every day.
Your fucking madman.
You probably a little tipsy.
Sometimes you drive,
you know you might smoke cigarettes,
you definitely smoke cigars,
you know,
you probably order shots,
right?
That's a ridiculous person.
So Fun ass fucking car.
But yeah,
Quito on weekends.
Look at the.
The transmission.
Not only is it an automatic,
it's a wheel.
So you spend a drive like fuck you.
First of all,
give me a goddamn stick shift like an
American.
I want to stick shift with the fucking
American flag as the boot of the stick
shift.
It's one of the last places on the
planet.
We could still get a goddamn stick
shifts.
Sports car and what it's for.
Do they release the GT 500 with an
automatic.
How dare you?
Don't talk to me about paddles both.
You can shift it manually with the
paddle.
That's not a manual transmission,
sir.
That's shifting.
And with the paddles.
Where's my.
What's my left foot doing?
Should I pretend?
How about give me a fake clutch.
Clutch record.
Pretend they looked dope though.
We've got it.
Good.
That silver one?
It looks sexy.
Several with the black stripes.
Goddammit.
So the red one with the black stripes
too.
So these come out later this year at the
end of the year Kinda?
Yeah,
I think so.
Are they.
I guess they haven't announced it yet so
I don't think they have announced a
specific data comes out,
but it looks like it's got wider
bodywork too,
doesn't it?
Like the fenders are wider and the rear
and the front.
But you if you want,
if you don't want to wait,
you can get something even more
powerful.
That is available right now with a
manual transmission.
You get the shelby super snake Google
that you want to see America at.
It's rock hard,
finest.
Two thousand 19 or 18 shelby super
snake,
800 motherfucking horsepower wide body
Mustang with a manual transmission and
they say don't even fuck with the
automatic because the automatic
transmission is the transmission from a
regular automatic Mustang and it just
doesn't know what the fuck to do.
I mean it's just,
it's,
it's confused by this thing.
The car is 800 horsepower.
Turn that volume up
to me,
that's sexy,
but net worth 117 pounds
getting a communist mouth.
That is a monster of a car.
Good Lord,
that's a beautiful thing
on your tesla.
Can you download sound effects that
sounds like that.
You don't want that.
You want to just just be cool.
Just chill.
Tesla's like you're,
you're a man of leisure.
You're a man of leisure and driving
around.
Comfortable and quiet is it flies
It's like it's going through a wormhole
everywhere.
You drive it.
Very strange car.
Have you tried to self driving?
Have you?
Um,
nerve wracking,
isn't it?
Having prayer.
It took me on at once and it's pretty
scary.
Yeah.
Bryan county does that thinks beaten
awful lot.
Was driving.
Put Porn on that big screen on here.
You can know.
Yeah.
That's great.
Can you imagine just driving,
people are on autopilot just beaten off
to porn.
That giant ass screen.
Does it have a web browser in it seems
like I haven't even looked,
man.
I'm sure it does something.
Yeah,
you could probably get online if it's
parked or something ridiculous like
that.
It's a crazy car,
but it,
it,
it's,
it seems like such a leap from anything
that I've ever driven before.
Like,
I've never,
I've never experienced anything remotely
close to it,
so let's go fucking play some quick.
So,
um,
I said everything I wanted to say about
the,
the Jack Dorsey thing,
um,
I've said everything I wanted to say to
Alex Jones,
so my olive branch extended to you,
Mr Jones.
I wish you well in this life.
Um,
and everybody else will do better.
We're going to definitely have jack back
on and we're going to have jack back on
and review some of these cases with some
of the people that are in charge with
it,
um,
of it rather.
And we're going to compile a list.
We're going to try to get someone to
compile a list of what they think would
be contradictory cases or hypocritical
cases are interesting cases or just fuel
for conversation and we'll figure it
out.
And uh,
and yeah,
the cash apps.
One of the sponsors of the podcast,
I'm 99 point nine percent sure we said
that
I'm not positive we did because we
talked about Justin wren fight for the
forgotten charity about what that code
word Rogan is doing for pygmies in the
Congo.
When they do that,
I swear to you,
even though you don't have to believe
me,
that did not affect how I talked to that
guy.
I don't have a problem getting sponsors.
I got plenty of sponsors.
It's a good sponsor.
I liked them.
They do good things.
They donate $5 to UFC fighter Ray Borg
son's medical bills for every time
someone uses the code Joe Rogan.
So I like them.
If I had them as a sponsor and I
couldn't talk freely with him,
I would be happy if they dropped me,
I would be way happier for them to drop
me than I would for me to say something
different or not say something because
they're a sponsor.
Again,
that sounds very self serving,
like you would say that.
Right?
But it's true.
So that's all I can tell you.
All right,
so that's it for today.
Bye.
Bye to everybody.
I see ya.